ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN. BIGELOW
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH BONTA
BRO. BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY. COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO. SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS MR OMAHA'S. THANK YOU OF
MISTER SPEAKER. THE SONG THAT
I'M GONNA SHARE IS CAREER
BIRDSONG IT IS ONE OF OUR
CREATION SONGS THAT TALKS ABOUT
HOW THE WORLD WAS DARK. IN THE
MOON MENDOZA SAYS WELL I LIKE
THE WAY FOR THE PEOPLE. AND
THEN THE COTTONTAIL RABBIT SAYS
WELL MAKE A TRAIL FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT NIGHT SO THEY CAN
FIND THEIR WAY. AND THE SUN
VOMIT. SAYS WELL I MAKE THE WAY
FOR THE PEOPLE DURING THE DAY.
IN THE BRUSH RABBIT JACK RABBIT
SAYS WILL MAKE THE TRAIL FOR
THE PEOPLE. DURING THE DAY. AND
WE'RE TOLD THAT IF WE FOLLOW
THOSE TRAILS LONG ENOUGH. THE
LEADERS TO WATER. IT'S AN HONOR
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO OPEN UP.
IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH THIS
PRAYER IN RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE. GIVEN THE RULES
SO AND MADE KIDS YVONNE AND
LITTLE LITTLE AND WHILE OFTEN
THERE. IS ON AND MOLD LITTLE.
AND MEIJI IS ON. RULES RULES
I'M LOCKED IN THERE ISLAM AND
MORAL LITTLE AND ME TOO ISM SAD.
MOVES A LITTLE WHILE. SMALL
LITTLE TOWN MAMBO NAY. MEN NEWS
SONG. THE SCHOOL. IS FOLLOW
RULE OF LAW. IS ON FOR A LITTLE
LITTLE AMAECHI IS LAUNCHED A
SMALL LITTLE HAMMERLOCK ON
THERE ISLAM AND MOVES A LITTLE
AND MADE KIDS IS ON FOR A
LITTLE LITTLE COM LAW FROM A
ARMED MEN NEWS PHAM YEAH AND
THE J. ON SCHOOL WINNERS BOB
RULE Là FROM A IS ON FOR A
LITTLE LITTLE DAMAGES HE
LAUNCHED A LITTLE LITTLE TIME
OFF FROM A THEN NEWS SONG YEAH.
ME TOO COOL WINTERS
. BOB DOLE
TOM LAUGHLIN. IT IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JULY
ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN THESE
ONLY MET AT NINE AM ON WILL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THIS ON THE PRESIDING CHEAP
CLICKY DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK READING CAR COMPANY AND
LOUIS READING THE ROLES CALLED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALLED MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR FLORA
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE
. MEMBERS WE ARE ADDS
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN AND
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
SPEAKER RENDON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARAMBULA CHAN IRWIN AND RAMOS
HAVE GUESTS. AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CARILLO
SANTIAGO EGGMAN. FRIEDMAN
GONZALEZ WAS RIVAS MEDINA OUT
ROBERT RIVAS KALRA STONE AND
WALDRON TO SPEAK ON IN GERMAN
IN MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR MCGUIRE FROM
THE RULES COMMITTEE. IN ORDER
TO BUILD SECOND READING I'LL-
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SEVEN I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
SB THREE FORTY TWO HERTZBERG TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RESCIND THE ACTUAR
BY ON JUNE TENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SB TWO THIRTY TWO
DODD. WAS READ A THIRD TIME
PASS IN ORDER TO THE SENATE
PLEASE ORDER THE BILL TO THE
THIRD READING FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. AND I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT ROLE
SIXTY TWO WAY THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
HEAR SB THREE FORTY TWO
HERTZBERG ON WEDNESDAY. AUGUST
TWENTY FIRST. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
. MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO. I AM REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB SIX THIRTY FIVE
BIGELOW TO THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE. AN ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE A. B. EIGHT EIGHTY
OBERNOLTE TO THE COMMUNICATIONS
AND CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
DOCTOR CHEN YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER FOR TIME I
SOME SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY TODAY FROM MY DISTRICT
HEATHER AND HER DAUGHTER ERICA
HAS ALL THE WAY FROM CHINO
HILLS. BILL WENT TO BE WITH US
TODAY ERICA THE SOPHOMORE CLASS
PRESIDENT YOU HOLD HIGH SCHOOL
HE'S A BASKETBALL PLAYER A
SCHOLAR AND PERHAPS A FUTURE
LEGISLATOR SOMETIME THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN.
ME IN WELCOMING COLLINS FAMILY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN YOU HAVE NUMBER OF
GUESTS WITH US TODAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR STUDENT
TEAMS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CYBER. INNOVATION CHALLENGED.
THE CHALLENGE IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INSTITUTE AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO. AND TOOK PLACE THIS
PAST JUNE ON CAL CALORIES AND
CAMPUS. IT BRINGS TOGETHER
TEAMS OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE TO WORK
AS DIGITAL FORENSICS
INVESTIGATORS. AND RESPOND TO A
CYBER ATTACK. THE TEAM'S
JOINING US TODAY IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
ARE. NORTH HOLLYWOOD HIGH
SCHOOL WHO PLACE FIRST FROM LOS
ANGELES WHERE ARE YOU NORTH
HOLLYWOOD HIGH SCHOOL. FORTY
FOUR HIGH SCHOOL FROM FULLER
TUNE WHO PLACED SECOND WORST
FOR HIGH SCHOOL. RIGHT. WE'RE
NOT A HILLS CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL
WHO PLACED THIRD FROM LA
THEY'RE UP THERE. AND THAT SHE
CHARTER OF PARADISE WHO
COMPETED DESPITE LOSING THEIR
SCHOOL CAMPUS AND BEING FORCED
TO LEAVE THEIR COMMUNITY DUE TO
THE DEVASTATING CAMPFIRE WHERE
ARE YOU ACHIEVE. THE TEAM
COACHES AND CAPTAINS ARE IN THE
REAR THE CHAMBER AND THE REST
OF THE TEAMS ARE IN THE GALLERY
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE CYBERSECURITY
CHAMPIONS TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
CORKERY SENATE BILL SEVENTY
WITH AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS HAVE
BEEN DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY. THAT IS ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY IS HR FIFTY FIVE.
PAUSE FOR ONE MOMENT MEMBERS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE FILE THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY. H.
R. FIFTY FIVE. MEMBERS PLEASE
KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE IN THE CHAMBER WE
ARE ON BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS RELATIVE
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY MISTER RAMOS YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE AS THE
FIRST CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN. ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. IT IS MY HONOR TO
PRESENT HR FIFTY FIVE THAT
RECOGNIZES FRIDAY SEPT WENT
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH AS THE
FIFTY SECOND ANNUAL CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY.
ACKNOWLEDGING THE HORRIFIC
TREATMENT TOWARD CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE IS ONE THAT WE
MUST CONFRONT AND EDUCATE THE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN OUR STATE OF
THE TREATMENT INFLICTED ON
CALIFORNIA INDIANS. A TREATMENT
I CAN PERSONALLY RELATE TO SEE.
MY CLAN THERE YOU HAVE IT THEM
PEOPLE IN SAM OR DO YOU KNOW
COUNTY. WEARING TEEN SIXTY SIX
I'M ALICIA WAS FORMED TO RID
THE MOUNTAINS OF ALL INDIAN
PEOPLE. THERE WAS A THIRTY TWO
DAY MASSACRE WHERE LESS THAN
THIRTY MEMBERS OF MY CLAN
SURVIVE. AND WAS ALMOST WIPED
OFF THE EARTH. FOR NOTHING MORE
THAN SIMPLY BEING INDIAN. THIS
HISTORY AND TREATMENT TOOK
PLACE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
IS A SPECIALLY HISTORIC BECAUSE
ARE SITTING GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM HAS ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER APOLOGIZING FOR THE
STATE'S CAMPAIGN OF ATROCITY
AND GENOCIDE THAT TOOK PLACE
AGAINST CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE. WE WILL NEVER BE ABLE
TO AND DO THE PAIN THAT HAS
BEEN INFLICTED UPON US OR THAT
LIVES WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES. BUT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO BRING FORWARD
A PROCESS OF HEALING THAT MUST
INCLUDE HONEST CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S TRUE AN
UNPLEASANT PASSED.
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE DRIVEN
BY THIS ELECTED BODY THE SENATE
THE GOVERNOR AND EDUCATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
IS ABOUT BUILDING BRIDGES AND
BRINGING A CULTURAL AWARENESS
OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE
INTO THE COMMUNITIES OF OUR
STATE. AND TO CLOSE THE GAP
THAT EXISTS IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR STATE. I STAND HERE TODAY
AS A STATE LEGISLATURE WAS
SERRANO AND COOLEY A BLOOD. TO
ENCOURAGE THIS BODY THAT WE MAY
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE YEAR
TO START THIS PROCESS AND BRING
UNITY AN HONOR TO OUR ANCESTORS
WHO PAID THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
WITH THAT MISTER SPEAKER I ASK
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CALL AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISS
ROMANS. ANY MEMBER SEE
RECOGNITION PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES SEEING NONE THE
AUTHORS ASKING OF THE FIRST
ROLL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR AUTHORS
ADDING ON TO H. R. FIFTY FIVE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MISTER RAMOS. MR
ROMMEL'S AND MISTER GLORIA YOU
ARE GOING TO BE RECOGNIZE FROM
THE REAR THE CHAMBER FROM MY
DESK. FOR A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION MISTER RAMOS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT IS A
PRIVILEGE TO RECOGNIZE THE
BOARD MEMBERS OF THE NEWLY
FORMED CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
CHAIRPERSONS ASSOCIATION. ON A
DAY LIKE TODAY. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY THAT A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO CORRECTLY
ADDRESS CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
FIVES IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE. THEIR
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE UNITY AND
STRENGTH BY ADVOCATING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE.
STANDING NEXT TO ME AND WITH
ME. IS CHAIRMAN VOTE WAS ANY
OTHER RECALL BAND OF THE SANYO
INDIANS. CHAIRMAN MICHAEL
HUNTER COYOTE VALLEY BAND OF
POMO INDIANS. GERMAN GUARD
SUNBURN. OF THE TRINIDAD
RANCHERIA. IT CHAIRMAN DALE
MILLER OF THE ALPHA VALLEY
RANCHERIA. TOGETHER THEY
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS ASSOCIATION CHAIRMAN'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO WHO COULD MAKE
THE TRIP TODAY INCLUDED
CHAIRWOMAN ERICA PAINT ALL OF
THE WHOLE MOVIE INDIAN VILLAGE
THANK CHAIRMAN KEVIN DAY OF THE
TWO WOLLEMI BAD TO ME WHAT
INDIANS. TOGETHER WE CELEBRATE
FAURIA INDIAN CULTURE. TODAY WE
HONOR THE CHAIR PEOPLE BEHIND
ME TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PLACE
OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD LET'S
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
.
MEMBERS MOVING BACK TO GUESS
INTRODUCTIONS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GAS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE ATTENTION TO DOCTOR
ARAMBULA FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION DOCTOR ARAMBULA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
IT IS MY PLEASURE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE UNITED HAVE A MULTI
COMMODITY MEMBER. OWNED
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION WHICH
IS DEDICATED TO PROVIDING
INNOVATIVE EMPLOYEE HEALTH
BENEFITS AND SOLUTIONS TO ALL
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE WITH US
TODAY ARE TWO OF THE SPONSORED
LEADERSHIP GROUPS THE WOMEN ACT
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY AND THE
EMERGING LEADERS ACADEMY CLASS
BOTH SELECT GROUPS OF
AGRICULTURAL PROFESSIONALS ARE
HERE TODAY. TO EXPAND THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PUBLIC POLICY
PROCESS AND TO FIND AVENUES
WHERE WE CAN CONTRIBUTE IN A
WAYS THAT WILL BENEFIT OUR
SOCIETY PLEASE HELP ME IN
WELCOMING THESE GROUPS TO THE
CAPITAL THEY'RE LOCATED IN THE
GALLERY UP TO OUR LEFT
. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE THE
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. YEAH.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
A CA ONE. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS NATURALLY THE LOCAL
FINANCE MS AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT A CA ONE A LEGISLATIVE
INITIATIVE TO ASK OUR STATE'S
VOTERS IF THEY WILL REDUCE THE
NECESSARY VOTER THRESHOLD FOR
LOCAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS FROM
TWO THIRDS TO A 55%
SUPERMAJORITY. UNDER CURRENT
LAW 55% IS THE SAME VOTE
THRESHOLD THAT IS NEEDED FOR
LOCAL SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION BONDS.
IN OUR STATES DEMOCRACY ONE NO
VOTE SHOULD NOT COUNT TWICE AS
MUCH AS ONE VOTE IN FAVOR OF
LOCAL INVESTMENT IN NEW HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. WITH
THE PAST ACA ONE WE ARE ONLY
ASKING VOTERS TO DECIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE LOST CRITICAL
TOOLS TO FUND PRIORITY PROJECTS
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES LIKE
REDEVELOPMENT. THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS WILL NEVER
BE ABLE TO FUND EVERY LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITY. A CA
ONE WOULD PERMIT ARE LOCALS TO
ASK THEIR VOTERS IF THEY
SUPPORT BONDS OR SPECIAL TAXES
THAT HAVE A SPECIAL SPECIFIC
EXPENDITURE PLAN. CITIZENS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ANNUAL
AUDITS AND TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY SUFFER FROM CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS RUN DOWN POLICE AND
FIRE STATIONS AND THE LACK OF
PARKS AND RECREATION NOT TO
MENTION STATEWIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. THIS MEASURE
WILL EMPOWER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO TACKLE LOCAL PRIORITIES AS
WELL AS BECOMING STRONGER
PARTNERS IN LEVERAGING PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE FUNDING. ALL. I ASK
WITH A CA ONE IS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND LETTING THE VOTERS
DECIDE. TO BE CLEAR. NOTHING IN
THIS BILL INCREASES ANYONE'S
TAXES NOTHING IN THIS BILL
REQUIRES A LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
PROPOSE A FUNDING MEASURE TO
ITS VOTERS. WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
WHAT IT DOES DO IS PRESENT THE
QUESTION TO OUR VOTERS OF
WHETHER OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A
REALISTIC FINANCING MECHANISM
TO HELP THEM BEST SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. ACA ONE WILL LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD BY PROVIDING
PARITY BETWEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS SO THAT ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL HELP YOU WILL
HAVE AN EQUALLY VIABLE
FINANCING TOOL TO ADDRESS
COMMUNITY NEEDS. WITH A VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF A CA ONE TODAY WE
ARE PROVIDING OUR VOTERS WITH
THE POWER TO GIVE THEIR LOCAL
LEADERS THE ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE. AND SEEK FUNDING
FOR PROJECTS THEY NEED IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY MR FRAZIER YOUR
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS CO AUTHOR ENSURE THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I RISE
IN TOTAL TOTAL SUPPORT FOR A CA
ONE. ACA WILL PROVIDE THIS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH A
REALISTIC FINANCING OPTION TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. CITIES
COUNTIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS
HISTORICALLY FACE CHALLENGES IN
SECURING FUNDING FOR IMPORTANT
LOCAL PUBLIC PROJECTS.
INVESTING COMMITTEE PROJECTS
PAYS OFF IN MULTIPLE WAYS
INCLUDING HOUSING CLOSER TO
THEIR JOBS AND LIVING IN AREAS
WHERE THEY HAVE A CHOICE OF
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS. THIS
BILL PROVIDES CLEAR VERY CLEAR
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE FUNDING IS
SPENT APPROPRIATELY INCLUDING
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS FOR VOTER
PROTECTION. PUBLIC NOTICE
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTABILITY. AS A
HUGE SUPPORTER OF THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND THE SELF HELP
COUNTIES THROUGH THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE THERE'S
TWENTY FOUR OF THEM NOW. THERE
CAN TO CONTRIBUTING THROUGH
THEIR. ONLY MEASURES FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND
HELPING THE STATE IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. MAKING
INVESTMENT IN THEIR LOOK LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WITHOUT THAT
WILLINGNESS TO DO SO THESE
CITIES AND COUNTIES WOULD BE
FAR BEHIND WHERE THEY'RE AT NOW
I RICHER AYE VOTE. THANKS FOR
YOUR DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND A COLLEAGUE SIDE RISE SAW
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF A CA
ONE. COLLEAGUES SO THE PURPOSE
SET IN OUR CONSTITUTION IS VERY
CLEAR IN REGARDS TO A TWO
THIRDS MAJORITY VOTE IN TAX
RELATED MATTERS. BORDERS TO
HAVE A REPEAT IT IS SUPPORTED
THE TWO THIRDS REQUIREMENT SO
SET IN THE CONSTITUTION THROUGH
A PROPOSITIONS ARE LIKE A PROP
THIRTEEN SIX A TWO AND A TWO
HUNDRED SIX EIGHTEEN. BY
REMOVING THIS OF THRESHOLD
DON'T WE ARE MAKING IT EASIER
TO RAISE OUR TAXES ON ALREADY
OVER TAXED TO STATE. ISN'T IT
ENOUGH FOR THOUGHT WE ARE
ALREADY PAYING HIGHEST ATTACKS
ARE IN THE COUNTRY. IN MANY
AREAS. THE PURPOSE IS TABLETS
DOWN IN SETTING THE TWO THIRDS
MAJORITY VOTE THOUGHT FOR TAXES
WAS TO CAPTURE THE ENTIRE
POPULATION ONE MAJORITY WHAT
TWO OR TWO THIRDS DEVASTATED.
NOT JUST OR A SEGMENT THE WHOLE
OF THE. TAXPAYERS IF WE REMOVE
THIS A PROTECTION THE DAMAGES
SO AND THE EFFECTS SO IT WOULD
BE FAR REACHING FOR THESE
REASONS I STRONGLY URGE YOU
KNOW VOTE. MR OF REALTY YOUR
ADDRESS I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
A CA ONE. THIS BILL WOULD LOWER
THE VOTING THRESHOLD FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO INCUR BONDED
INDEBTEDNESS FROM THE TWO
THIRDS REQUIRED IN PROP 13255%
THE TWO THIRDS REQUIRED. OF
MAKING THESE GOVERNMENTAL
DECISIONS IS A VERY APPROPRIATE
VOTE THRESHOLD AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THE DECISION TO ENTER
INDEBTEDNESS IS AMONG THE MOST
SERIOUS DECISIONS THAT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAKE. WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT AN
EXPENDITURE THE JUST OCCURS
THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN MOST CASES
GOING INTO DEBT FOR TWENTY
YEARS. WHEN YOU CHOOSE TO
BORROW MONEY. THAT MEANS YOU'RE
CHOOSING TO REPAIR IT OVER TIME
WITH INTEREST SO EVERY DOLLAR
THAT WE BORROW TODAY. TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR ROAD
REPAIR WE COULD DO TWICE AS
MUCH AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
REPAIR TWICE AS MANY ROADS IF
WE CHOSE TO PAY AS WE GO
INSTEAD OF GOING INTO DEBT. SO
THE DECISION TO IT BONDED DEBT
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS ONE.
THAT IS APPROPRIATELY A
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE
THRESHOLD. BUT I'VE A FURTHER
CONCERN ABOUT THIS BILL AND
THAT IS BECAUSE THE BONDS THAT
ARE FINANCED BY THESE TAXES ARE
PAID BY PROPERTY TAXES WHICH
WILL INVARIABLY INCREASE THE
COST OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ALL KNOW. DIRE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE COST OF
HOUSING HERE ALREADY WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST POVERTY OF ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST HOMELESSNESS OF ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY. THIS BILL
WILL MAKE THAT SITUATION MORE.
BUT COLLEAGUES. YOU CAN ARGUE.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE NOT
HURTING. WE'VE GOT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT ARE FLIRTING WITH
BANKRUPTCY I HAVE ONE OF THE
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT. IS
TALKING ABOUT DISSING
CORPORATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A ENOUGH REVENUE TO MEET
THEIR OBLIGATIONS. BUT HOW DO
YOU RECONCILE THAT WITH THE
FACT THAT WE GET A TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS
AT THE STATE LEVEL THIS YEAR.
COLLEAGUES WHAT WE HEAR IS NOT
A REVENUE PROBLEM IT IS A
REVENUE ALLOCATION PROBLEM.
LASTLY. I WOULD ARGUE THAT THIS
BILL IS COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LAST
ELECTION CYCLE AND YOU LOOK AT
THE VOTE THRESHOLD THERE WAS
REQUIRED THEIR OF TWO THIRDS
AND YOU TALLY ALL OF THE BONDS
THAT PASSED DID YOU KNOW THAT
OVER 80% OF THE BONDS ON THE
BALLOT LAST CYCLE PASSED OVER
EIGHTY PERCENT. SO THE QUESTION
IS WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD BE
AN APPROPRIATE VOTE THRESHOLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK. MESSAGE RATE
WE WANT MORE THAN 80% OF THE
VOTE THESE BONDS TO PASS.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS BAD FOR
CALIFORNIA IT MORTGAGES OUR
CHILDREN'S FUTURE FOR THE SAKE
OF POLITICAL EXPEDIENCY TODAY
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP. I'M PLEASED TO
BE A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR IN
THIS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
MEASURE. YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY
THIS BEFORE WE ALL KNOW THIS
THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF THE
WORST HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
RIGHT NOW UNFORTUNATELY THE
CURRENT THRESHOLD FOR LOCAL.
MEASURES TIED THE HANDS OF OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THIS ACA'S
CRITICAL TO ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO INVEST LOCAL
DOLLARS BACK IN A HOUSING
PROJECT INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT IS ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL. I
WON A REMINDER COLLEAGUES A TWO
YEARS AGO WE PLAYED THE STATE
WIDE. AND AFFORDABLE HOW ONE
PROPOSITION ONE ONLY NEEDED A
SIMPLE MAJORITY TO PASS IT DID
IF IT HAD BEEN LOCAL PARK SURE
IT WOULD HAVE FAILED.
REQUIREMENTS TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD LOCAL
MEASURES FAIL UNDER THIS
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS EVEN
THOUGH THEY GOT WELL OVER A
MAJORITY OF VOTES WE ARE
ALLOWING IT 234% MINORITY TO
RULE THE DAY. WE SPOKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THERE ARE SO
MANY INTERSTATE. THAT NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GET THE RESOURCES TO
PAY FOR. FOR WHAT WE REALLY
NEED NGUYEN DRESSES ISIS WE
NEED TO ADDRESS A HOMELESSNESS
ON OUR STREETS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- THANK
YOU MISTER CHIU MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK THANK A SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M RISING OBVIOUSLY IN
OPPOSITION. I WANT US TO THINK
VERY SERIOUSLY ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES. OF REDUCING A
THRESHOLD FOR PASSAGE. WITH
REDUCING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REDUCING. THE PROMISES MADE AND
PROMISES KEPT TO THE VOTERS
THAT WE PRESENT THESE BONDS AND
EXPENDITURES TO WHAT DO I MEAN
BY THAT THE TWO THIRDS
THRESHOLD HAS HISTORICALLY
REQUIRED THE PROPONENTS OF THE
DEATH. TO BE VERY CLEAR ON WHAT
IT'S GOING TO GO FOR. WE HAVE
SCHOOL BOARDS FOR EXAMPLE THAT
I'VE SUPPORTED. BOND INCREASES
FOR VERY GOOD REASONS WHY
BECAUSE WHEN THEY WENT TO THE
BALLOT BOX AND HAD TO GET THE
TWO THIRDS THRESHOLD THEY WERE
VERY VERY CLEAR. ABOUT THIS
SCHOOL WILL RECEIVE THIS THIS
WILL RECEIVE BACK THIS IS OUR
PROMISE. THAT NUMBER TWO I COME
FROM A SELF HELP COUNTY. ONE OF
THE VERY FIRST POLITICAL. I
INVOLVEMENTS WAS WITH MEASURES
SEEK WHICH IS A TRANSPORTATION.
TAX IT REQUIRES THE TWO THIRDS.
IT HAS DONE WONDERS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY IN FACT YOU CAN DRIVE
AROUND THE FIFTH LARGEST CITY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ABOUT A TWENTY OR TWENTY
FIVE MINUTE DRIVE TIME IN THE
WORST. TRAFFIC LOCATIONS IT HAS
BEEN OUT NOT ONLY PASSED BUT
HAS BEEN PASSED AGAIN. WHY
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO GET TO THE
TWO THIRDS THRESHOLD. IT
REQUIRED US TO BE VERY VERY
CLEAR. ON WHAT WE WERE GOING TO
DO WITH THE MONEY. I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A LANGUAGE WITH
RESPECT TO WELL THERE'S GOING
TO BE OVERSIGHT AND OTHER KINDS
OF THINGS. MY POINT IS THAT AS
YOU REDUCE THE VOTE THRESHOLD
YOU INHERENTLY REDUCE THE
OVERSIGHT. IT BECOMES MORE AND
MORE ON NECESSARY TO BE VERY
VERY SPECIFIC AND TO DEAL WITH
THE THOSE WHO WOULD SAY I LIKE
THE IDEA OF BEING A SELF HELP
COUNTY BUT I WANT TO HAVE MORE.
RESPONSIBILITY WITH MY VOTE TO
BE ABLE TO REQUIRE THAT A
PARTICULAR PROJECT BE
ACCOMPLISHED AND BE DONE. SO
I'M I'M I'M ASKING YOU TO
RECONSIDER THE BASIC PREMISE
HERE. THE HIGHER THRESHOLD NOT
ONLY. GIVES THOSE WHO ARE
PROPERTY OWNERS AND WILL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY AFFECTED BY IT.
ALL THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN
BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
PROPONENTS AND I'VE BEEN ON
THIS SIDE OF BEING A PROPONENT
AND HAVING TO COME TO A TWO
THIRDS VOTE AND TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO THE VOTERS. AND SAY THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS IS OUR
PROMISE TO YOU AND THE HIGHER
THAT THRESHOLD THE MORE DIRECT
AND CLEAR OUT WE HAVE BEEN. AND
SO I WARN YOU AGAINST THE
PRESUMPTION HERE THAT IF YOU
RAISE YOUR REDUCE THE-
THRESHOLD THAT YOU GET BETTER
BOND EXPENDITURE I DON'T THINK
YOU DO I THINK THE HIGHER THE
THRESHOLD THE MORE SPECIFIC AND
DIRECT A COMMITMENT. WE MUST
MAKE IN ORDER TO GET IT PASSED
IT IS NOT MERELY A PROTECTION
FOR THOSE WHO WILL BEAR THE
MOST BURDEN OF SPUR EXAMPLE
PROPERTY TAX INCREASE. BUT IT
IS A IT REALLY IS A GUARANTEE.
THAT IF YOU ARE AS CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE AND YOU PUT UP SIGNS
ALL ACROSS YOUR SCHOOL BOARD
LOCATIONS IN SCHOOLS A SAID
THIS GETS A CAFETERIA THIS ONE
GETS A- GYMNASIUM. THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT I
THINK THE THRESHOLD. UP
REQUIRES THE PROPONENTS TO DO.
AND INSTEAD OF RUNNING AWAY
FROM A THRESHOLD OF
ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK WE
SHOULD BE EMBRACING A THRESHOLD
ACCOUNTABILITY WE GET THOSE
PASSED 80% OF THEM HAVE BEEN
PASSED. I BELIEVE IT'S BECAUSE
TOLD US HIGH AND SO THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE PROMISES AND THEN KEEP
THEM IS ALSO A HIGH THRESHOLD.
FOR THOSE REASONS I WOULD
SUGGEST A NO VOTE. DOCTOR
WOULD. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D I APPRECIATE THE
DEBATE HERE AT I WOULD POINT
OUT I BELIEVE IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN THAT. SCHOOL BOND
MEASURES ARE AT 55% CURRENTLY.
SO 55% IS THE NUMBER THAT I
UNDERSTAND I ALSO POINT OUT
THAT WE ARE NOT THIS IS PAT
VOTING TODAY DOES NOT PASS THIS
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT GOES
BEFORE THE VOTERS TO LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT
TO CHANGE THE THRESHOLD OR NOT
SO I RISE TO IT TODAY AS A CO
AUTHOR TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
THE POSITIVE IMPACT IT COULD
HAVE ON MY RURAL DISTRICT.
COMMUNITIES IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO MANY OF
THE RESOURCES PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT PROVIDE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IT THAT
URBAN COMMUNITIES DO FOR
EXAMPLE BROADBAND INTERNET
HINDERS EVERYONE FROM SCHOOL TO
SCHOOL CHILDREN TO THE BILL
COMMUNITY I DON'T HAVE IT WE
DON'T HAVE IT FOR ECONOMIC
FELLOW WE DON'T HAVE. FOR A LOT
FOR EDUCATION. WE DON'T HAVE A-
AREAS FOR TOP OF LIKE LIKE I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. IT IS MY
COMMUNITIES THAT WANT TO RAISE
A SPECIAL TAX OR A G. O. BOND
DEFINED INFRASTRUCTURE OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS. IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES FACE SPECIAL
CHALLENGES. EDUCATING VOTERS IN
ADVOCATING FOR BALLOT MEASURES
IN COMMUNITIES THAT CAN SPREAD
OUT OVER HUNDREDS OF MILES CAN
PROVE IMPOSSIBLE FOR SMALL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
STRAPPEDFOR RESOURCES. MEMBERS
TO SIMPLE AMENDMENT IS THE KIND
OF YOUR WE SHOULD BE PUTTING ON
THE BALLOT. AND GIVEN THE
VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DECIDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THEY THAT WOULD
MISTER COOLEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN THE AIR UNUSUAL PLACE OF
ACTUALLY I KNOW A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES FAVOR THIS I
ACTUALLY STRONGLY OPPOSE IT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO SPEAK
TO I THINK THE DISCIPLINE. OF
ANY IN A COMMUNITY IN A TWO
THIRDS CONVERSATION. IT ONLY A
DISCIPLINE IN A DEMOCRACY THAT
BROADENS PARTICIPATION SHARED
COMMUNITY VALUES. CONFRONTS
POLARIZATION. IT IS A SALVATORI
EXPERIENCE TO HAVE TO SPEAK TO
A LARGER COMMUNITY. WHEN A LONG
TERM FINANCIAL GROUP IS BEING
MADE. IN MY CAREER I
PARTICIPATED IN NUMEROUS.
BALLOT FIGHTS INVOLVED A TWO
THIRDS VOTE AND ACTUALLY FEEL
IT IS A WHOLESOME JUST WANTED
DEMOCRACY TO HAVE TO REACH OUT
TO BROAD LINES. I ACTUALLY.
HAVE AN ISSUE SOME WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL THE TAX PIECES OF THE ONES
A BOTHER ME WHEN I STARTED THIS
BILL IN SO LONG AGO IT WAS
BEFORE PROP THIRTEEN. NOW I
REMEMBER THE MOST OF TAXATION
GOING TO THE ROOF. AND IMPEDED
MY ABILITY TO BUY A HOME.
BECAUSE I WAS A RUNNER WHEN I
STARTED HERE. IN THE CURRENT
CLIMATE I KNOW YOUNG YOUNG
COUPLES OUTSTANDING COUPLES
CELLPHONE EMPLOYED COUPLES WITH
WITH GOOD JOBS WORD ABOUT.
BUYING A HOME IN CALIFORNIA. I
KNOW YOUNG COUPLES ARE THINKING
GEE MAYBE WE SHOULD UNDERTAKE
TO GET OUT OF READING. FIND A
WAY TO RUN A MOTOR HOME. AND
LIVE THROUGH YOUR STARTED I
TENER WAY TO SET ASIDE FUNDS SO
THEY CAN SOLVE A CONUNDRUM OF
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. SO I'M
ACTUALLY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE TAXATION PIECE OF THIS. I
DON'T BELIEVE IT IS IT'S SUCH A
BIG ARTICLE BECAUSE THIS IS A
DEMOCRACY. THE GLOBE NEEDS
EXAMPLES OF DEMOCRACIES THAT
LISTEN EVERYBODY. THE PUBLIC
POLICY DEBATE ACTUALLY RECKONS
WITH THE VIEWS OF PEOPLE
THEY'RE DIFFERENT TO BE. AND
MOVE THE STATE FORWARD. I THINK
THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA THINGS IMPORTANT IN
THE GLOBAL. SO I ACTUALLY FEEL
AS I SAY GOOD WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIESTS I THINK
THE TAXATION PIECES BAD I DON'T
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THE BURDEN.
THE CHALLENGER GET INTO TWO
THIRDS I THINK THAT REQUIRES A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF SKILL SET. SO
THE CAMPAIGN I LOGS OF THE
DEATH BUT ENGAGING PEOPLE
LISTENING AND WORKING TO GROW
CONSENSUS AROUND A FUTURE.
WHETHER IT'S OF WHATEVER TYPE.
WE'RE BASE OF THE CAMPAIGN IS
ABOUT WHAT IS EXIST IN THE
STATUS QUO IS INIMICAL TO THE
WELL BEING OF PEOPLE. AND
THEREFORE THEY WILL SERVE BY
GOING TO DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
WHICH CAN INCLUDE UNDERTAKING
OF FINANCIAL OBJECTIVES YEAH IN
MY OWN COUNTY I WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN MEASURE REIN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOR MY FIRST NINE
MONTHS IS ELECTED OFFICIALS.
AND WORKED THERE TWO THIRDS
VOTE IN SECOND COUNTY AS A SELF
HELP COUNTY. BUT THE IN EVENTS
SO I LOOK AT THIS I ACTUALLY
FEEL THERE'S IMPORTANT
DEMOCRATIC VALUES IMPLICIT IN
THIS I DON'T THINK THE TWO
THIRDS IS AN INSUPERABLE
BARRIER INDEED I THINK IT.
TESSA BRUCEI COMMITTEE WHERE.
YOU WORK THROUGH THE
DIFFERENCES SO YOU PULL
TOGETHER WORKING ON THE FUTURE
I THINK THAT'S A GREAT ASSET.
THERE WAS COOLEY MS GONZALEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IS A CO
AUTHOR IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF A
CA ONE IT'S NO SECRET THAT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE UNDER
ENORMOUS PRESSURE TO MAINTAIN
OUR EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THAT REALITIES COMPOUNDING ARE
GROWING NEED ADDRESS NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS BECAUSE I
CLASS CHANGE POPULATION GROWS
GROWTH DEFERRED FINANCE. IN ON
TOP OF THAT WERE ASKING HER
COMMUNITIES TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR
CONSTITUENTS. SOMETHING THAT.
SOMETIMES IS A LITTLE TOO
DIVISIVE TO GET A TWO THIRDS
AGREEMENT UPON WHERE THAT
SHOULD BE. IT'S TIME WE TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR OUTDATED TWO THIRDS
APPROVAL REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL
MEASURES WHICH ONLY SERVES TO
HAMSTRING OR COMMUNITIES FROM
TAKING LOCAL PRIOR TEETH INTO
THEIR OWN HANDS WITH A MAJOR
PORT. FOR MAJORITY VOTE WHEN
PROP THIRTY NINE PASSED WE
LOWERED THE THRESHOLD FOR
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION WANTS TO
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT. AND WHAT
HAS HAPPENED HAS BEEN GOOD. AS
WE SEE IN OUR SCHOOLS IMPROVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND OUR
SCHOOLS WE'VE ALSO SEEN A LOT
OF GOOD LOCAL JOBS WE'VE RE AND
IN HER GREAT AT THE ECONOMY THE
LOCAL ECONOMY AT THE SAME TIME.
AS DOING GOOD FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN DO THAT
AGAIN TODAY. AC WHAT A CA ONE
SIMPLY EMPOWERS VOTERS TO MAKE
THAT DECISION TODAY I'D IT'S
TIME TO LOWER THAT THRESHOLD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY WHICH DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN YOU'LL BE
VOTING FOR THIS A CA WHEN IT'S
ON YOUR BALLOTS MEANS. THAT YOU
RESPECT YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
TO ALLOW THEM TO VOTE ON IT.
THERE WAS GOODS ALSO MISTER
BONTA YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE AS A CO AUTHOR AND A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF A CA ONE A
TWO THIRDS SUPERMAJORITY
THRESHOLD AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS
UNDEMOCRATIC. WHEN ONE THIRD
PLUS ONE OF THE VOTERS TERMINA
FUTURE FOR A LOCALITY AND UP
OUT VOTE TWO THIRDS MY ONE OF
THE VOTERS SOMETHING IS VERY
WRONG. THE TWO THIRDS MAJORITY
THREE. BONDS AND TAXES BUYS ON
THE FALSE PREMISE THAT THE
VOICES OF THOSE WHO WISH TO
INVEST IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
ARE SOMEHOW. LESS VALID. LESS
IMPORTANT AND LESS VALUED THAN
THOSE WHO OPPOSE THOSE
INVESTMENTS. IT'S WRONG THAT WE
REQUIRE THAT TWO OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
LOCAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING PUBLIC
SAFETY OR TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS FOR EVERY ONE. PERSON
WHO SIMPLY SAYS NOW. NOW MORE
THAN EVER OUR COMMUNITIES NEED
EVERY TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
ADDRESS THE SERIOUS HOUSING
CRISIS. AFFECTING OUR STATE
CHANGING THE VOTING THRESHOLD
255% WOULD ESTABLISH A BETTER
STANDARD FOR VOTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ONE IN WHICH THEY
ARE EMPOWERED TO VOICE THEIR
CONCERNS. ON LOCAL MATTERS A CA
ONE IS SIMPLY GIVING A
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ANOTHER TOOL
ONE THAT IS MORE FAIR ONE THAT
IS MORE DEMOCRATIC TO INVEST IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND PUBLIC
IN TRUCKS ACCEPTS BACK FULLY
ASKED WE AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA MISTER GLORIA YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE A PROUD CO
AUTHOR TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM WINTERS ON
SUPPORT OF A CA ONE MEMBERS ALL
OF US CAME TO OFFICE MANY OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS CALLING UPON
US TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT OUR
STATE TERRIFIC HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND
DEMANDING THAT WE DO WHAT WE
CAN TO INVEST IN OUR PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE DESPITE SOME OF
THE MANY HER ROGUE EFFORTS THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE VOTERS
HAVE DONE. STILL IS INADEQUATE
FOR THE SIZE THE NEED OF THE
GROWTH THAT WE EXPERIENCING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ACA ONE
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE
TO CONTINUE ON THE PATH THAT
WOULD RUN. WE'RE GOING TO
DIFFERENT ROCK A ROUTE WHERE
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA THAT WORKS
REALLY FOR ALL OF US ALLOWS
MORE PEOPLE TO ENVISION A
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY AFFORD TO LIVE HERE
AND WE'RE NOT WE'RE ACTUALLY
DIRECTLY INVEST IN OUR PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE I'VE HEARD WITH
RESPECT POLICIES RATE THE ISSUE
OF THE FIRST TIME HOME BUYER.
WELL AS I UNDERSTAND FROM
READING OF THE PRESS THE ONLY
ONE ON THE SCHOOL AS AN ART
FORM. AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT THE SOCIALIZED COSTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WE BOUGHT ME
WHAT FROM EIGHT TO PUT. OTHER
NAY. PILE NO NO IT'S. LONG AGO.
THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GONNA GET
OUT OF THIS CRISIS IS WE WORK
ON THIS ALL COLLECTIVELY
TOGETHER. AND UNFORTUNATELY AS
YOU KNOW THE BAR RIGHT NOW IS
TOO HIGH. THE BAR WAS SET WHERE
IT WAS SET NOT TO ACTUALLY
FACILITATE THIS BUT
SPECIFICALLY TO MAKE IT. A
CREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO ACTUALLY
GET THE FOR PROGRESS THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS EXPECT FOR US.
THEY DEMAND FROM US ON ABOUT
YOU I HAVE TOWN HALL MEETINGS
PEOPLE TALK TO ME ALL THE TIME
WHAT ARE YOU DOING ABOUT
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY WHEN YOU
GONNA FIX THE HIGHWAY WHEN YOU
GET A PAVE THE ROAD. WENT AGAIN
TO FIRE STATION IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND I RECOGNIZE
IT IF WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS
ON THE BALLOT. IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE. YOU ALL MANY OF YOU
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
YOU'VE EXPERIENCED THIS
YOURSELF. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I
WORK TOGETHER WITH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS BIS IN LETZTER
TRANSPORTATION ADVOCATES BARTON
WAS TO PUT TOGETHER
COMPREHENSIVE. MEASURE SAN
DIEGO CAN. AFFECT THE THREE
MILLION PEOPLE WHO COSTS INYO
COUNTY HOME DESPITE THAT I'M
PRESIDENT COALITION WE GOT 58%
OF THE VOTE BUT AS YOU ALL WELL
KNOW FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT. IS
NOT ENOUGH. THE PROGRESS THAT
WE NEED TO SEE AND CHANGED OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM PRESERVING OUR OPEN
SPACE AND INVESTING IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS IT'S STOCKS.
BECAUSE A MINORITY OF PEOPLE
SAID THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO.
MEMBERS SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT
IN THIS COUNTRY WHEN DONALD
TRUMP CAN BECOME PRESENT NOT IT
STATES WITH 46% OF THE POPULAR
VOTE AND YET CALIFORNIA COULD
NOT INVEST IN ITS NEIGHBORHOODS
EVEN WHEN FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT.
OF ITS RESIDENTS AGREE. LET'S
DO SOMETHING TO CHANGE THIS
YOUR VOTE TODAY IS NOT
DETERMINATIVE YOU WELL KNOW
THAT THIS IS ABOUT GIVING THE
PUBLIC THE RIGHT TO VOTE ON
THIS MATTER. AND IF I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO MY CONSTITUENTS I
KNOW THAT THEY WANT ME TO VOTE
YES AND I WILL BE DOING THAT
TODAY I WANT IT'S CLOSE BY
GETTING MY EXTREME RESPECT. TO
THE MEMBER FROM WINTERS THIS IS
NOT AN EASY CONVERSATION BUT
IT'S ONE THAT HAS BEEN. IGNORED
FOR TOO LONG AND IT IS TIME
THAT THIS LEGISLATION DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT GIVE THE
PEOPLE THE RIGHT TO VOTE. VOTE
YES ON A CA ONE. THANK WAS
GLORIA DOCTOR QUIRK. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I RICE IS A CO
AUTHOR OF A CA ONE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'LL JUST
MAKE ONE POINT IT'S BEEN SAID
THAT 80% OF THE BOND ISSUES
THAT HAVE TWO THIRDS DO PASS
THAT YOU'RE SHOWS THAT YOU
DON'T PUT A BOND ISSUE UP. IF
YOU HAVE 58% APPROVAL. THERE
MAY COUNTIES WHICH CAN'T DO
THAT A LOT OF CONNIE'S TRIED
FOREVER. TO GET TO DO WHAT MOST
MANY COUNTIES HAVE DONE. UP
WHICH IS TO HAVE A SELFIE A
SELF HELP COUNTY IN TERMS OF
GETTING UP ROADS DONE THEY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PASS THEY JUST.
FOREVER REASON CAN'T REACH TWO
THIRDS I THINK 55% IS ENOUGH
THANK YOU. DATA CORPORATION IS
AREA YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND I JUST WANTED TO. MAKE A
BRIEF A NOTATION OF A COUPLE OF
POINTS ONE IS THAT IT SEEMS
LIKE WE CONFUSE OUR COMMITMENT
TO KEEPING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFE WITH BEING FINANCIALLY
PRUDENT WHICH I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU SERVE ON
A COMMITTEE SUCH AS THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD AND SEE TO
WHAT EXTENT WE- SERVE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND SOME OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO ALL
TOO WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUCH. UP WITH THE BODIES
ALLOCATE FUND NECESSARY FUNDING
TO THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
DISTRICTS WHERE BOND AFTER BOND
HAS FAILED. THAT'S WHY I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT OF SELF
HELP HERE. BOND AFTER BOND HAS
FAILED. AND THAT'S WHY THE RELY
UPON THIS STATE TO COME IN AND
GIVE THEM THE ENTIRETY OF THE
100% OF FUNDING FOR HELPING OUT
WITH THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
INSTEAD OF JUST A FIFTY
PERCENT. BECAUSE OF THE 50%
LOCAL AND STATE MATCH. YET WE
STAND HERE AND WE TALK ABOUT
HOW WE SHOULD BE FISCALLY
PRUDENT. THE THIS IS A ZERO SUM
GAME. IT'S EITHER GOING TO BE
PAID FOR FROM THE STATE. FROM
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IF WE CAN
GET SOME ACTION AND SUPPORT OR
IT'S GONNA COME FROM MORE
VOTERS BUT WE CAN'T GO BACK AND
CAMPAIGN AGAINST MEASURES.
DEFEAT THEM AND THEN COME BACK
IN BACK CHANNEL WE ASK FOR MORE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE. AND
MAKE IT SOMETHING THAT THE
ENTIRE STATE HAS THE
CONSTITUENT RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE HAVE TO PAY FOR WHEN PART
OF THAT OBLIGATION IS INCUMBENT
ON OUR LOCAL RESIDENTS TO PAY
FOR. JUSTIN LA I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT OF SOME YEARS
AGO OF THE FOUR YEARS AGO WE
HAD A TRANSPORTATION MAJOR
TRANSPORTATION BALLOT WHICH
FAILED BY. THREE POINT 3%
POINTS. AND WE HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE COST ALL OVER AGAIN
TO PLACE IT BACK AND GET IT
PASSED THE SECOND TIME AND THAT
WAS LA WHICH PROBABLY HAS THE
HIGHEST OBLIGATION WHEN IT
COMES THE BOND DEBT SO WITH
THAT I ADAMANTLY SUPPORT AND
VIGOROUSLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THERE
SEEMS TO BE A GREAT MYSTERY
TODAY AS TO WHY WE CAN'T GET
SOME OF THESE BOND MEASURES
PASSED WITH A TWO THIRDS VOTE
SO LET ME HELP SOLVE IT FOR YOU
IT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN'T
AFFORD IT. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT IT. IF YOU CAN'T GET THE
THRESHOLD THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
SET. BY LAW THAT MEANS PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO. YOU MIGHT WANT
IT BUT THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
PAY THE BILL DON'T. PEOPLE ARE
GONNA BE PAYING THAT BILL FOR
TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS DON'T
WANT THAT INVOICE. THERE'S NO
REASON TO CHANGE IT I THINK THE
VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN IF SOME OF
THESE BOND MEASURES HAVE FAILED
THAT'S WERE GOOD REASON BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO BUY WHAT
YOU'RE SELLING. I REGION ABOUT.
ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
HAVING SEIZED ON THE ITEM. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL I TAKE A LITTLE EXCEPTION
TO A FEW THINGS BUT I WILL SAY
IS THAT YES FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR ALL
OF US WHEN FIRST BY YOUR FIRST
HOME. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT. MY
COMMUNITY AND I LOOK AROUND.
AND THEY ARE SAYING TO ME THE
SENIORS NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I NEED MY SENIOR
SOMEWHERE. IF YOU'RE SENIOR IS
THE SUM IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT OPENS UP SOME OF THE
INVENTORY YOUR COMMUNITY. AND I
THINK WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP
SOME OF OUR SENIORS BE ABLE TO
GO TO OTHER PLACES TO BE ABLE
TO AFFORD A PLACE AS THEY AGE
ON. I THINK ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE SIT HERE
NUMEROUS TIMES HOW MANY TIMES I
HAVE I HAVE. BEEN ASKED TO VOTE
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE CLEAN WATER HOW
MANY TIMES WE HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS. THIS IS A WAY TO
HELP YOUR COMMUNITIES DO SO.
YOU KNOW THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
BROUGHT UP BROADBAND. MY
COMMUNITIES FIGHT FOR BROADBAND
MY COMMUNITIES CAN EVEN GET
HEALTH CARE ACCESS BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT IF I TELL HEALTH IN THE
COMMUNITY KNEW THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE A SPECIFIC PROJECT. THIS
FUNDING TO GO THROUGH THEY DO
IT. YOU KNOW. ASSEMBLY ROOM
MELINDA'S YOU KNOW THERE ARE
MANY PEOPLE THAT DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THE VOTES GO
THEY ASSUME THAT EVERYTHING IS
A 55% OR 50% MOST PEOPLE DO NOT
UNDERSTAND IT'S A TWO THIRDS
THEY JUST DON'T. I DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU TELL ME THEY DON'T.
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A TAX THIS
IS SIMPLY ASKING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IF THEY WANT TO
HAVE A SPECIFIC PROJECT. IN
THEIR COMMUNITY THAT THEY WANT
TO BUILT. REFER REFURBISH
THAT'S ALL IT DOES THIS IS ALL
THIS IS JUST ASKING GIVING
PERMISSION TO CITIES TO RUN
THESE OF ALL THE IS GUYS I'M
NOT ASKING FOR A TAX. I'M NOT
YOUR COMMUNITIES MAKE THIS AND
MAKE THIS DECISION ON THEIR OWN.
YOU KNOW THIS TAKES COURAGE
EVERYONE. BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW MUCH OF IT HOW MANY OF YOU
HAVE COURAGE TODAY THIS IS NOT
A TAX I'M ASKING YOU TO STAND
UP FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS I'M
ASKING YOU TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR
PEOPLE BY PROVIDING THEM THE
POWER TO MAKE DECISIONS IN
THEIR OWN. BACK YARD. WE CAN'T
DO IT ALL FOR WE ALL KNOW THAT.
BUT LET THEM AND LET THEM MAKE
UP SOME OF THIS MONEY WHY CAN'T
THEY LEVERAGE SOME OF THEIR
MONEY FOR FEDERAL MONEY WHEN IT
COMES FOR OPEN. WHY CAN'T WE
LET THEM DO THAT. THEY ARE THE
ONES ARE CONSTITUENTS KNOW WHAT
PROJECTS MATTER TO THEM. THEY
KNOW WHAT'S MANAGED TO THEIR
CHILDREN THEY KNOW WHAT IT IS
TO THEIR FAMILIES. OUR
COMMUNITY SUFFER FROM CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS AFTERMATH OF NATURAL
DISASTERS SEA LEVEL RISE RUN
DOWN POLICE AND FIRE STATIONS.
LACKS THE PARKS AND RECREATION.
NOT TO MENTION AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO ASK OUR LEADERS TO
WAIT. FOR THE DAY THAT THEY'RE
PROJECTS READ REACH THE TOP OF
THE STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING
LESS. HOW MANY TIMES A YEAR
PEOPLE SAYING I CAN'T GET THE
MONEY I CAN'T GET THAT EXTRA
SET OF MONEY I'M WAITING FOR
THE FEDS OF THE STATE. LET THEM
HELP GET THAT FUNDING. MEMBERS.
I ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING
NEEDS OF EACH OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
THAT STILL REMAIN UNFUNDED AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
FOR A CA ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY IN WITH THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL ALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. RESERVE A
.
SIX FIFTY FOUR. YEAH ALL
MEMBERS BETTER IS OUT OF OUT
.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR VOTES
. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY
. MS AGUIAR-CURRY
MOVES A CALL
. PAGING THE
ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM. MS
BARRETT QUE HAN
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE VERY BRIEFLY BACK
TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS IS PARA
QUE HAN HOUSE OF GAS IN THE
GALLERY WHO ARRIVED MISS PARA
QUE HAD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO INTRODUCE THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD STAFF INTEREST IN
CAMPUS ADVOCATES THAT ARE IN
THE GALLERY TODAY THE WORKING
HARD THIS SUMMER IN YEAR ROUND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADVOCATING FOR WOMEN IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR THAT AND-
THEN THE YOU CAN SEE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY SEE IF. AND YOU
KNOW THAT EACH OF US STANDS
WITH YOU THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW BE MOVING TO THE
CEREMONY TO RECOGNIZE OUR
ASSEMBLY FELLOWS
. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY FELLOW CEREMONY AT
THIS TIME. DURING THEIR ELEVEN
MONTH TENURE WITH US THE
ASSEMBLY FELLOWS HAVE SERVED US
IN A WIDE RANGE OF STAFF
FUNCTIONS NEARLY HALF OF THE UP
OFFICES IN THE LEGISLATURE
EMPLOYEE FORMER FELLOWS. FROM
THE EXECUTIVE JUDITH SENATE OR
ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS.
OTHER FORMER FELLOWS ARE NOW
MEMBERS OR OFFICERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES UNIVERSITY INSTRUCTORS
EXECUTIVES OR COMMUNITY LEADERS
THEY GO ON TO DO GREAT THINGS.
I ASKED SPEAKER IN RENDON AND
REPUBLICAN FLOOR LEADER MARIE
WALDRON TO MOVE TO THE CENTER
AISLE FOR THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES AND
GUESTS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN JESSE MARVIN UNDER
ANDREW ASSEMBLY FELLOWS THE
CLERK WILL READ. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY IS
EACH CELL DESK AS RODRIGUEZ SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF HARVARD
COLLEGE
. YEAH. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA IS A
RESERVE THIS YEAR OF MED SHE IS
A GRADUATE OF UNIVERSITY OF THE
PACIFIC
. ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN IS ARIEL AYALA
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF LOYOLA
UNIVERSITY CHICAGO
. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA IS IT
REAL SALDIVAR ESTEBAN HE'S A
GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEN
IS AARON HOLES IN SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY
. ESCORTED BY SOMEONE
NUMBER DAVID CHIU IS A VERY ON
CHRISTIAN THEY ARE A GRADUATE
AT CSU CHICO
. ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER FLORA IS SHANE
GILLARD HE'S A GRADUATE OF CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO
. ESCORTED
BY FAMILY MEMBER FONG IS NINE
OH JOE SINCE HE IS A GRADUATE
OF HILLSIDE COLLEGE
. ESCORTED
BY FAMILY MEMBER GALLAGHER IS
ALEXANDER J. RESPEITO IS A
GRADUATE OF CSU NORTHRIDGE
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA IS FOR CAL MASON SHE IS
A GRADUATE OF OCCIDENTAL
COLLEGE
. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN IS WESLEY
WHITAKER HE IS A GRADUATE OF
CLAREMONT MCKENNA COLLEGE
. IT'S
FORTY FIVE. ESCORTED BY A
FAMILY MEMBER JONES SAWYER IS
ERICA NO SHE IS A GRADUATE OF
WITH YOUR COLLEGE
. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER LACKEY IS HIGHLY
BULGE SHE IS A GRADUATE OF
DOMINICAN UNIVERSITY
. ESCORTED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ AS
MADELINE KLINE SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF SONOMA STATE
UNIVERSITY
. ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBER MULLIN IS JORGE REINA
SALINAS IS A GRADUATE OF CSU
NORTHRIDGE
. ESCORTED BY SOME
THE NUMBER REYES IS MERYL PRESS
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC SAN
DIEGO
. YEAH. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM IS
BENJAMIN TRAN HE'S A GRADUATE
OF UC IRVINE
. ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER WEBER IS KERA PAT
AND SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC
DAVIS
. THANK YOU WE WANT TO
WELCOME THE KEY GASES WELL FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDIES IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER ARE LEONORE EVENING
ANYTHING YOU JERK. AS WELL AS
HIM CHIU. WE ALSO WELCOME THE
OTHER STAFF IN THE CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA STUDIES THE PARENTS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF THE
FELLOWS THAT ARE IN THE
GALLERY. THERE WILL BE A
RECEPTION HONORING THE FELLOWS
IN ROOM THREE SEVENTEEN THAT
WILL BEGIN. IMMEDIATELY. AS THE
BELLAS EXIT THE CHAMBER LET'S
GIVE THEM ANOTHER ROUND OF
APPLAUSE
. THIS CONCLUDES OUR
CEREMONY THANK YOU EVERYONE.
WILL MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. THE SECOND READING
FILE. SECOND READING WE ARE YOU
DO IT OKAY WHERE DID SECOND
MEETING SO WE WILL MOVE. TO THE
CONCURRENCE
. FILE ITEMS TWO AND
THREE WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN
WILL PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM FIVE
WILL BE PASSED RETAINED MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SIX AB THREE
THIRTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN THE PEACE
OFFICERS. MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THREE THIRTY TWO IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL
AIMS TO IDENTIFY ANY POTENTIAL
BARRIERS WITHIN A PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING. ACADEMIES AND IT'S
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES THUS FAR
WE WANT TO KEEP THAT GOING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM SEVEN
THROUGH TEN WILL BE PASSED AND
RETAINS MOVING BACK UP IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM FOR AB TWELVE
SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE SIXTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES MR RIVAS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWELVE SIXTY SIX IS A BILL TO
PROMOTE BICYCLE SAFETY AND
DANGEROUS TRAFFIC INTER SHINS.
THE SENATE AMENDMENT THE
PRODUCT OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH
CALTRANS TO SURE EFFECTIVE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD IMPLEMENTATION.
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE. VOTE
ON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED AS ARE THE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
NEWS ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ELEVEN AB SEVEN THREE
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY SELLING NUMBER EIGHT
MEN AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH
FACILITIES THIS EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU IN A
SPEAKER AB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE READ INCREASING
THE- SAFETY OF ELDERS IN. LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. GIVE US EGGMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE ISEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEMS TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN WE PASSING RETAINS.
MOVING. WIENER FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND ACT LIKE
THE ATHLETES MR CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SAM MEMBERS I RISE TO
UP PERCENT AB FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENT TOWARD A TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND CLARIFY THAT IT IS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE AND TO
ENSURE GENDER EQUALITY IN THESE
CHANGES. WILL HAVE NO OPPOSITE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSE.
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ AS A LEGAL SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT BASED ON THE
NUMBER OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY
THE SEARCH WARRANT MR OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MOST CARS IN
CALIFORNIA OR EQUIPPED WITH AN
EVENT DATA RECORDER THAT
RECORDS. SOME DATA FROM FIVE
SECONDS BEFORE AN ACCIDENT TO
ONE SECOND HALF AFTER AN
ACCIDENT THIS DATA IS VERY
USEFUL TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATING THE CAUSE OF AN
ACCIDENT CONTAINS THINGS LIKE
THE SPEED OF THE VEHICLE THE
POSITION OF THE STEERING WHEEL.
AND THE PERFORMANCE OF THE SEAT
BELTS HOWEVER LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS NO PATH UNDER CURRENT STATE
LAW TO GET ACCESS TO THIS DATA
IF AN ACCIDENT OCCURS THAT
SERIOUSLY INJURES RESULTS IN
THE DEATH OF THE VEHICLE
OCCUPANTS. THIS BILL CREATES A
VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED PATH FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO
GET ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION
ONLY OF IN THE EVENT OF AN
ACCIDENT COPPING SERIOUS BODILY
INJURY OR DEATH AND ONLY WITH
THE PERMISSION OF THE COURT AND
THE SHE WAS A SEARCH WARRANT.
SUPPLEMENTS FURTHER NARROW THIS
BILL TO ONLY THOSE OFFENSES
THAT ARE SUSPECTED IT TOO IF OF
THE COMMISSION OF A MISDEMEANOR
IN OTHER WORDS NOT CIVIL
INFRACTIONS. COLLEAGUES THIS
BILL STRIKES AN APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN THE NEED TO
PROTECT THE PRIVACY CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS ON THE ONE HAND AND
THE NEED FOR POLICE AGENCIES TO
INVESTIGATE THE CERES ACTS ON
THE OTHER. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR CONCURRENT SEVEN
MONTHS. THANK MISTER LTC SEEING.
AND HEARING NO FURTHER BASED ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. NUMBER THIRTY
LAWMAKERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THIRTY
VOTE. CLAIRE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE
AND ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE MR
DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THIS IS THE ANNUAL OMNIBUS BILL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED A
NON CONTROVERSIAL PROVISION. IN
THE SENATE PASSED THIS WITH
MERRY A NO VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE FOR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
DALY SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEMS TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY FOUR OF PASSED
THE RETAINS. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTION. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN AB TWELVE FIFTY ONE SAN
DIEGO TO THE SENATE FOR FURTHER
ACTION. THAT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MOVING TO
THE THIRD READING FILE. FILE
ITEMS TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
SIX WE PASS THIRTEEN FILE ITEMS
TWENTY EIGHT. THROUGH THIRTY
FIVE WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN.
FILE I'M THIRTY SIX ACR ONE OH
TO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BIGELOW RELATIVE TO MASS TIMBER
PRODUCTS. MR BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ACR ONE OR
TWO OR JUST THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO ADOPT
RULES FOR THE USE OF MASS
TIMBER PRODUCTS. FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION. BY
ADOPTING RULES FOR THE USE OF
MASS TIMBER PRODUCTS CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE. THE FUEL FOR WILDFIRES
IN ADDITION TO REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS TYRE TONIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. MOM
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. HOW
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE IT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NOES
THREE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN ACR ONE
OH FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOMETHING CURRENT POSITION ONE
OH FIVE PRICE ONLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS REALTY TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. MR CHIU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES OUR NATION
IS GRAPPLING WITH A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICE CRISIS
WITH SIX FIGURE PRICE TAGS FOR
MEDICATIONS BECOMING A REGULAR
OCCURRENCE A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN
ON PATIENTS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. EARLIER THIS YEAR
GOVERNOR TOOK BOLD ACTION BY
TACKLING SKYROCKETING DRUG
PRICES IN HIS FIRST EXECUTIVE
ORDER HOWEVER THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER DID NOT EXTEND TO WORKING
WITH OTHER STATES BOTH OREGON
AND WASHINGTON HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION URGING THEIR
RESPECTIVE STATES TO PARTNER
WITH CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE DRUG
PRICES THIS RESOLUTION
CONFIRMED OUR COMMITMENT TO
LOWERING THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. AND
ENCOURAGES OUR GOVERNOR TO
ENGAGE WITH THE STATES OF
WASHINGTON AND OREGON WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY NO ZERO THIS RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. WE WILL. PASS THE
ROUTINE AND FILE ITEMS THIRTY
EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE. FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE SB FOUR NINETY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE MR STONE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THAT FIGURE
MEMBER THIS IS SENATOR RISE
THOSE OMNIBUS FAMILY LAW BILL
COMING OUT OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. MERELY ADD CO
AUTHORS AND PROVIDE CHAPTER GOT
AMENDMENTS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT IN BACK TO FILE. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS.
FORTY TWO FOR FORTY SEVEN PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN FILE
ITEMS FORTY NINE THROUGH FIFTY
FIVE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIX. SB THREE SIXTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR RUBIO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
AND STUDENT SAFETY. IS QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB THREE ONE
SIX THIS BILL ALLOWS PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO PRINT THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER FOR THE
NATIONAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINE ON THE BACK OF STUDENT
ID CARDS THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
REPORTS THAT EVERY YEAR ONE IN
FOUR ADOLESCENTS CLAIMED TO
HAVE SUFFERED FROM A TYPE OF
ABUSE BY A DATING PARTNER. SB
THREE SIXTEEN WILL PROVIDE
PUPILS WITH AN IMMEDIATE
CONFIDENTIAL AND SAY PHONE
NUMBER WHERE THEY MAY BEGAN
THEIR HEALING PROCESS THIS BILL
IS RESOLVED RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS KIRK BY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO THE- SMALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES. THE
BACK
. MOVING BACK UP IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
SB TWO NINETY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ CYNICAL TO NINETY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THE
AMENDMENTS TO SB TWO NINETY
FIVE CREATE A NON REFUNDABLE
CREDIT FOR QUALIFIED TAXPAYERS
DURING HER COST. FROM
PERFORMING QUALIFIED HOME
HARDING OR HOME VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT A QUALIFIED PROPERTY.
IN THE PAST TWO DECADES WE HAVE
SEEN A MARKED INCREASE THE
WILDFIRES IN IN IN THEIR
SEVERITY THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY ESTIMATES
THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON
FIRE HARDENING MEASURES TO
BRING BUILDINGS AT THE CURRENT
CODES FOR DOLLARS IS SAVED. NOT
TO MENTION THE SAVINGS OF
COUNTLESS LIVES BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF PROPERTY DAMAGE AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF AVOIDED
INSURANCE COSTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR FIVE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU IS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE WE CAN TAKE
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION WE COULD
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK TO FILE. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
FIFTY SEVEN THROUGH. SIXTY FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE SB TWO SEVENTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY FOUR WITH THE
MEMONS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
MOAN MISS THE MON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR
PROVIDES INCREASE PROTECTIONS
FOR MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS THE
AMENDMENTS TO SB TWO SEVENTY
FOUR ARE LARGELY TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND HAVE NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT. AND THE
REQUESTED THE BILL GO OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE THANK
YOU MISS THE MON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OF HIS SAY NO. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT IN BACK TO FILE. WE. WELL
PASS AND RETAIN A BY LEN SIXTY
TWO FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY
MEMBER GONZALEZ. MR DOLLARS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SENATOR WIENER SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
ALLOW DREAMERS AND OTHER
IMMIGRANTS TO RUN FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT THE ONLY
IMMIGRANTS ALLOWED TO RUN UNDER
THIS BILL WILL BE. DHAKA AND
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
RECIPIENTS GREEN CARD HOLDERS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN GRANTED
ASYLUM THE AMENDMENTS ALSO ADD
THE PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY THE
OTHER POLITICAL PARTY THAT IS
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN THIS
CONCEPT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEE
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
COULD TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO. AND
MEN SIR ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT IN
BACK TO FILE. PASSENGER CHANGE
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR THROUGH
SEVENTY THREE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SB SEVEN
FORTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY THREE
BY CENTER HERTZBERG AND
ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL FACILITIES.
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THE DESIGN BUILD METHOD OF
PROJECT DELIVERY PROVIDES MANY
EFFICIENCIES TO SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS INCLUDING
COST EFFECTIVE USE OF PUBLIC
FUNDS AND IN PARTICULAR
EXPEDITED PROJECT COMPLETION.
HOWEVER THE REQUIRED STATUTORY
CHAIN OF EVENTS IN DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTING AND SEE QUIRK
CONFLICT WITH ONE ANOTHER ON
ONE HAND WE HAVE DESIGN BUILD
AN EXPEDITED DELIVERY OF A
PROJECT THAT ALLOWS FOR A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO AWARD A
CONTRACT TO DESIGN. A BILL A
CONSTRUCTOR EXCUSE ME
CONTRACTOR THIS ALLOWS THE
DESIGN FOR THE PROJECT TO BEGIN
ON THE OTHER HAND WE HAVE SEEK
WELL WHICH REQUIRES FULL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REVIEW TO
BE COMPLETED BEFORE THE PROJECT
IS APPROVED. SB SEVEN FORTY
THREE HARMONIZES SEEK WHAT IN
DESIGN BUILD BY CLARIFYING THAT
AWARDING THE CONTRACT DOES NOT
MEAN APPROVAL PERCY CLASS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MESS MATH
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY THREE
NO ZERO. ROGER PASSES. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT SB TWO NINETY FIVE
ACQUIRED TO THE REV IN TAX
COMMITTEE INTO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
THREE SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT BY
SENATOR WINNER TO THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE AND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FIVE TO SEVENTY
SEVEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT SB FOR NINETEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FOR NINETEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
THIS PLAN. MR GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SENATE BILL FOR
NINETEEN SEEKS TO REDUCE
SUSPENSION RATES AND KEEP OUR
KIDS IN SCHOOL THIS BILL HELPS
IN THAT AFTER BY ELIMINATING
WILLFUL DEFINED SUSPENSIONS.
THROUGH GRADE FIVE PERMANENTLY
IN GRADES SIX THROUGH EIGHT
WITH A FIVE YEARS SUNSET. CURLY
THIS WILL FILL THE FILE IS VERY
SUBJECTIVE IN ITS CRITERIA
BROADEST DEFINITION IMPLEMENT
IT IN DIFFERENT WAYS IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
IN SOME SCHOOLS SUCH OFFENSES
THAT BEEN CHIPPING GUM WEARING
HEADPHONES HAVING YOUR HEAD
DOWN ON YOUR DESK AND USING A
QUOTE HOSTILE TONE. BLACK BROWN
A DISABLED KIDS ARE BEING
SUSPENDED FOR WILLFUL DEFIANCE
AT RATES MUCH HIGHER THAN THEIR
PEERS. STUDENTS WHO ARE
SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL
INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM YOU KNOW THE
REPERCUSSIONS SENATE BILL FOR
NINETEEN SIT STILL PRESERVES
THE RIGHT I WAS SAY THIS VERY
VERY CLEARLY. SENATE BILL FOR
NINETEEN STILL PRESERVES THE
RIGHT FOR TEACHERS TO REMOVE A
STUDENT FROM A CLASSROOM FOR
DESTRUCTION INDOOR DEFIANCE IT
SIMPLY MEANS THEY WILL NOT BE
REMOVED FROM THE SCHOOL.
MEMBERS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
HELP KEEP OUR STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOMS AND THEIR EDUCATION
IS NOT INTERRUPTED. ABOUT
CENTER SKINNER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER GLORIA MISTER CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER. MADAM SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SAW I RISE. IN
OPPOSITION TO AS BL FOUR
NINETEEN. COLLEAGUES SO I STAND
UP TO A POST THIS BILL BECAUSE
THAT'S ALL PASSED GOVERNOR
BROWN THE STADIA. TEACHERS AND
THE PRINCIPALS SAW ON THE
FRONTLINE IS EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN AND THE ARE IN THE
BEST POSITION TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS. ABOUT THE ORDER AND
THAT THIS BELOW NOT IN THE
CLASSROOMS. OUR LAWS ARE
CURRENTLY RESTRICT OUT THE USE
OF A SUSPENSION OF BY REQUIRING
THAT. IT ONLY BE USED OVER AND
OTHER MEANS OF A CORRECTION
FAIL. WE MUST LOOK TO ENFORCING
THE CAR IN LOSS IF THEY ARE
BEING IGNORED AND THE FOCUS ON
THE OVERALL ENVIRONMENT OF THE
CLASSROOM BEFORE JUMPING OUT TO
A NEW LAW SO AND THE
REGULATIONS. AS AN EDUCATOR
MYSELF Là I BELIEVE THAT THE
WE NEED TO A PLACE SO MORE
TRUST IN OUR EDUCATORS AND TO
GIVE THEM THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
BE ABLE TO PREPARE OUR CHILDREN
FOR THE FUTURE. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
VIDEO NO VOTE THANK YOU. YOU
MISTER TRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE. THERE MIGHT
WEBER. DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINETEEN
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
I THINK WITH A LOT OF THINGS
AND SPECIALLY THOSE WHO WORK
THE BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
PROGRAM NO. THAT COULD EASILY
BE APPLIED IN AREAS WHERE THE
NECESSARY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY WE TALK ABOUT
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KIDS WE'VE
HAD PEOPLE WHO TRY TO SUSPEND
KINDERGARTNERS AND FIRST
GRADERS FOR THEIR PERSPECTIVE
THIS AT SOME ON THE WRONG PATH.
AND WE NEED TO CHALLENGE
OURSELVES TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE CARED FOR THAT
THEY'RE IN THE SCHOOLS THAT THE
TIME IS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE
WHEN YOU START TO SPENDING A
CHAU YOU REALLY ARE PUTTING
THEM ON THE PATH FOR DROPOUTS
AND BEING OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM EVERY KID NEEDS TO BE
IN A SCHOOL WHERE THEY ARE
LOVED CARED FOR AND THAT. WE
HAVE THE- ENVIRONMENT IT'S
BASICALLY STAYING. I WAS
SHOCKED WHEN I SAW SO OFTEN IN
MY SCHOOLS. I HAVE A COUNCIL
WANTS TO SAYS PLEASE. OUR
SCHOOL EIGHT O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING SCHOOL STARTS AT EIGHT.
SHE WANTED ME TO COME. SO I
WENT TO HERS. BOB WENT TO THE
SCHOOL AND WENT TO THE- THE
LIBRARY WHERE HER CONFERENCE.
ROOM WAS A COUNSELOR. AND
PROBABLY THE BELL RANG EIGHT.
BY EIGHT TEN THE ROOM WAS FULL.
FOR WHAT KIDS OF PEOPLE DID ONE
DEAL WITH. THEY'VE SOLD AS A
CHILD WALKING SAVE ARE YOU CAN
HAVE A GOOD DAY I'M GOING TO BE
PROBLEMS TOO AGAIN DAY AND KEEP
THE PRICE SO YOU'LL PROBABLY BE
A PROBLEM AND SO THEY WOULD
SEND THEM OUT WITH A PACKET OF
MATERIAL AND SO SHE HAD.
STUDENTS ARE. IN FULL BECAUSE
THEY COULD BASICALLY. PUT
CHILDREN OUT OF CLASS. AT THEY
COULD ALSO SUSPENDED FROM
SCHOOL FOR THAT. WE DON'T NEED
TO DO THAT ALL THE RESEARCH
SAYS VERY CLEARLY. THE STUDENTS
WERE TAKEN OUT OF THE CLASSROOM
DURING THE DAY. DO NOT DO
BETTER THEY DO WORSE. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DROP OUTS AND
OTHER THINGS AND KIDS BEING
BEHIND WE HAVE AN ACADEMIC
ISSUE OF. A PERFORMANCE IN
TERMS OF KIDS WILL POUR. AND
THIS IS OFTEN DONE. TO KIDS OF
COLOR. AND WE SAW THESE WE SEE
THIS TIME AND TIME AGAIN WILL
PEOPLE MISINTERPRET THE ADDED
TO THEIR PERSPECTIVE. WHEN I
TELL MY KIDS TO CREATE A VITAL
TO TALK ABOUT. THE FACT THAT
WILL FULL DEFIANCE OF THE CHILD
HAS A BAD ATTITUDE. BUT
WHATEVER IT MAY BE. BUT THEY DO
NOT NEED TO BE SUSPENDED FOR
SCHOOL. WE DON'T NEED TO SET
THEM ON THIS PATH IS GOING TO
COST US EVEN MORE MONEY. AND
COPS AS AS A SOCIETY. WILL FEEL
WITH GRIEF. BOTH SCHOOLS CITED
NOT GOING TO SPEND KIDS KIDS
LEARN THAT VERY QUICKLY. AND
THEREFORE THE ADJUSTED THE
ENVIRONMENT. IT TOLD WITH THE
TEACHERS. SO I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT WE- OF SUPPORT.
BILL WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH
THIS SSUE AND WE'VE HAD. A
NUMBER OF PILOTS THIS FINALLY
THAT. FOR US. THIS. IS THE ONE.
FOR THE BASE. OF NOT. I'M
INTEREST GO THE LOS FORMATIVE
YEARS. AND I WOULD STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT WE SUPPORT THIS.
THAT WE KEEP OUR KIDS IN CLASS
WE FELT. FIGURE OUT ALTERNATIVE
WAYS AND ANY QUICK BY TEACHERS
WITH THE BILL. EVERY STUDENT
COMES TO THE DOOR BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO BE WE NEED TO BE THE
STATE IS FINALLY SAYS YES. WE
ARE NO LONGER INVOLVED IN
SUSPENSION OF KIDS FOR WILLFUL
DEFIANCE NOT VIOLENCE NOT
CARRYING WEAPONS BUT JUST
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A BAD
ATTITUDE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I BOTH THE S. BEFORE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER. IS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I ALSO REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SB FOUR
NINETEEN. AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER FROM ALL ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS TEACHING IN MANY MANY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. I TO
SPECIFICALLY WORKED WITH
STUDENTS THAT WERE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES MANY TIMES THE
STUDENTS WOULD BE PLACED IN
STUDY SKILLS CLASS. THEY WOULD
BE. IN SOME TYPE OF DETENTION
DURING THEIR LUNCH TIME AND
EVEN THE YOUNGEST OF STUDENTS
FROM KINDERGARTEN. FIRST SECOND
THIRD GRADE. OFTEN SPENDING
THEIR RECESS TIME SITTING
AGAINST A WALL PERHAPS FOR NOT
HAVING HOMEWORK. PERHAPS FOR
NOT FOLLOWING INSTRUCTIONS AND
WE SIMPLY NEED TO LOOK AT AND
FIND NEW WAYS TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS. THAT ARE HAVING
ISSUES MANY TIMES THOSE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE THE ISSUES
IN CLASSROOMS ARE TELLING YOU A
STORY. BY THEIR BEHAVIOR.
THEY'RE TELLING YOU SOMETHING
IS NOT RIGHT THAT THEY WANTED
TENSION. MANY OF THEM DON'T
KNOW. NEGATIVE ATTENTION
SOMETIMES GIVES A CONSEQUENCE
BUT THEY'RE STILL ASKING FOR
ATTENTION SO MEMBERS THIS IS
THE TIME FOR US TO START TO
LOOK AT WAYS TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS THAT ARE
NONTRADITIONAL YOGA MEDITATION
LISTENING TO THEM LETTING THEM
RIGHT. LETTERS LETTING THEM.
WORK INDEPENDENTLY BUT KEEPING
THEM ON THE SCHOOL CAMPUS AND
KEEPING THEM WITH THE OTHER
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE A
STUDENT THAT WE MAY KNOW OR A
FRIEND IN A CLASSROOM THAT WE
NEED TO BRING ALONG WITH US.
INSTEAD OF EXCLUDING I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER GLORIA YOU MAY CLOSE I
WILL TAKE THAT WORDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE BEEN
EDUCATORS BOTH OF SAN DIEGO AND
COMPLEX AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE ITEM. THANK YOU MISTER
WHERE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. WILL PASS AND RETAIN
FIVE ITEMS SEVENTY NINE THROUGH
EIGHTY TWO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE S. C. R. THIRTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
TWO BY SENATOR MORALE RELATIVE
TO THE UNITED STATES FOREST
SERVICE FIREFIGHTER BRANDT
MICHAEL WITH THEM THE MORAL
HIGHWAY. YOUR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN COLLABORATION
WITH CENTER MORRELL TO
RECOGNIZE A FALLING CALIFORNIA
HERO. BRENT MICHAEL WITH THEM
WAS A US FOREST SERVICE
FIREFIGHTER HE WAS A MEMBER OF
AN ELITE HOTSHOT CREW WHOSE
HAZARDOUS JOB IT WAS TO BE
DROPPED BY THE LINES OF A
FIREFIGHT WORK TO HIKE IN AND A
FIGHT THAT FIRE USING NOTHING.
BUT THE EQUIPMENT ON HIS BACK.
HE WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED TWO
YEARS AGO FIGHTING THE LOCAL P.
FIRED WESTERN MONTANA IN THE
LINE OF DUTY. THIS RESOLUTION
WOULD RENAME A PORTION OF STATE
ROUTE THIRTY EIGHT WITHIN MY
DISTRICT IN BROWN'S HONOR. I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE MEMORY OF THIS
BRIGHT YOUNG MAN. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH
EIGHTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE SB ONE THIRTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
ONE THIRTY FOR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG IN ASHLAND WATER
CONSERVATION MISS RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM OF.
MADAME IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB SIX ALL
SIX ESTABLISHING PERMANENT LONG
TERM WATER USE EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS AND GOALS ACROSS THE
STATE FOR THE FIRST TIME. THAT
LANDMARK LEGISLATION
ESTABLISHED AN INDIVIDUALIZED
WATER USE OBJECTIVE DETERMINED
BY THE SUM OF MULTIPLE FACTORS.
SB SIX OH SIX REQUIRED WATER
SUPPLIERS TO FIND SAVINGS
ACROSS THE RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL WATER
LOSS AN OUTDOOR USE. AFTER THE
SIGNING OF THAT LEGISLATION
THERE WAS A STRONG DISAGREEMENT
BETWEEN WATER SUPPLIERS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ON HOW THE
WATER LOSS STANDARD WOULD BE
ENFORCED. THE ARABIC WORD
AMBIGUITY ALLOWED FOR A DOUBLE
JEOPARDY PROBLEM WHERE THE
WATER LOSS STANDARD COULD BE
ENFORCED TWICE FOR A SINGLE
VIOLATION. SB ONE THIRTY FOUR
CLARIFIES RIGHT FULL
ENFORCEMENT PRACTICE.
SPECIFICALLY SB ONE THIRTY FOUR
DETERMINES THAT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WILL
ENFORCE IN A CUMULATIVE
PERFORMANCE STANDARD INSURANCE
ENSURING THAT THE VOLUME WATER
LOSS IS NOT ENFORCED SEPARATELY
FROM THE OTHER FACTORS. IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT THE WATER BOARD
CANNOT IMPOSE PENALTIES FOR
EXCEEDING THE WATER USE
OBJECTIVE IF THE WATER AGENCY
IS EXIT EXCEEDING ITS WATER USE
OBJECTIVE SOLELY BECAUSE IT IS
EXCEEDING THE WATER LOSS
STANDARD. AND THE WATER BOARD%
IS IMPOSING PENALTIES ON THE
WATER AGENCY UNDER WATER LOSS
REGULATIONS. THE BILL PROVIDES
A CLEAR PATHWAY FORWARD FOR THE
WATER RESILIENCY AND ENSURES
THAT WATER SUPPLIES SUPPLIERS
ARE NOT PENALIZED TWICE FOR A
SINGLE VIOLATION. I
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS NINETY THREE NINETY SIX
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS NINETY EIGHT THROUGH
ONE OH TO MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE OH THREE SB THREE OH NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL THREE OH NINE BY SENATOR
RUBIO AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TAXATION THE CLING THERE AND
SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. CHRIS RUBIO YOU
ORGAN RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT SB THREE OH NINE
WHICH WOULD REMOVE THE MINIMUM
DONATION REQUIREMENT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
WAS RAISED IN ORDER TO REMAIN
LISTED ON THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX FORM. UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. CSL ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE TO ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS SHAPING POLICIES THAT
AFFECT OUR LIVES. PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATED ESTIMATES BACKED BY
THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY THE
STATE'S SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE
AND OLDER POPULATION WILL
NEARLY DOUBLE INCREASING BY
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE. WELL
BECOMING MORE RACIALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE THIS
WONDERFUL PROGRAM BEGAN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THROUGHOUT
THROUGH THE WORK OF SENATOR
HENRY MELLOW AND SINCE THEN
OVER TWO HUNDRED CSL PROPOSALS
HAVE BEEN ENACTED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW. WITH THE RAPIDLY
GROWING ELDERLY POPULATION WE
NEED TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING AND
PROVIDING FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RUBIO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
WHO DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO'S THERE TO VOTE. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NEWS
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE OH FOUR THROUGH ONE.
ELEVEN FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE SB
FOUR OH TO THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FOR A TWO BY
SENATOR BORDERS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES. AS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS CENTER
BARGES AND I REPRESENTING INYO
COUNTY REALLY CARE ABOUT INYO
COUNTIES ADVENTURE TRAIL PILOT
PROGRAM. THIS BILL SIMPLY
EXTENDS OF THE PILOT ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM THAT MAKE SURE. ALL
MORE OFF ROAD VEHICLES ARE
FOLLOWING THE RULES AND THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING OUR LANDS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
FIFTY SIX NO SEVEN MEASURE
PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTEEN. THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
MINING AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE CANNABIS CULTIVATION. MR
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
CENTER MUNNINGS SB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN ALLOWS THAT AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER TO REPORT CANNABIS
CROP SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY DO
WITH THE REST OF THEIR- CROP
REPORTS. THIS IS AN ADDITIONAL
REPORT TO THE CROP REPORT IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY OF THIS
REPORTING BUT ALLOWS THE-
ESTABLISHMENT OF CANNABIS AS A
LEGITIMATE CROP IN CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE WAYS WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD. IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO COMBAT
PIRACY AND BRING THIS INDUSTRY
INTO THE MAINSTREAM THIS IS A
BILL WITHOUT ANY OPPOSITION AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER STONE'S ING IN
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED USER TO
MOVE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO SEVEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY BUT WE WILL PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THROUGH ONE THIRTY ONE
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO SB SIX
NINETY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR HILL AND ACTUALLY TO
WATER. MR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO PRESENT SB SIX NINETY NINE.
THE BILL THAT WOULD EXTEND TO
SUNSET DATES TO CONTINUE THE
IMPROVEMENT. OF THE BAY AREA
REGIONAL WATER SYSTEM. FIRST IT
WOULD EXTEND STATE OVERSIGHT OF
SAN FRANCISCO'S REQUIRED
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM FOR
THE BAY AREA REGIONAL WATER
SYSTEM FROM JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TO JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX SECOND
THE BILL WOULD EXTEND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA REGIONAL
WATER SYSTEM FINANCING
AUTHORITIES ABILITY. TO ISSUE
REVENUE BONDS THROUGH DECEMBER
FIRST TWENTY THIRTY EXTENDING
THE SUNSETS WILL ALLOW THESE
PROJECTS TO BE COMPLETED
SMOOTHLY. AND WE STATE
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS INTACT THE
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN AND
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ERICO.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
ONE THIRTY THREE THROUGH ONE
FORTY TWO
. MEMBERS ARE PREPARED
TO LIFT THE CALL ON A CA ONE.
LOCAL POSTS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS ADDED THOUGH
. CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN. NO
SEVENTEEN. THAT MEASURE FAILS
AND MS AGUILAR CURRIED NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP. FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN ON CENTER THIRD
READING. THAT IS SB TWO THIRTY
FOUR. CORRECT SENATE BILL TWO
THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER
AND ACTUALLY THE FAMILY DAYCARE
HOMES MS BARRICADE HAND YOUR
RECOMMENDS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I PRESENT SB TWO
THIRTY FOUR ON BEHALF THE
SENATORS. CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE EXPERIENCING A
LACK HOUSE CARE LICENSE CHILD
CARE IS ONLY AVAILABLE 423% OF
CHILDREN WITH WORKING PARENTS
THE MEDIAN COST OF INFANT CARE
IN THE BAY AREA ROSE FROM
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
TO SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. SB TWO THIRTY FOUR WILL
HELP TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES.
BY TREATING PERMIT REQUIREMENTS
FOR SMALL AND LARGE FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES THE SAME. IT
CLARIFIES THE CHILD CARE IS
ALLOWED IN APARTMENTS AND
CONDOS. AND REQUIRES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
INFORMED CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
OF THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT TO HELP
PREVENT DISCRIMINATION. THIS
BILL INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY
OF QUALITY AFFORDABLE AND LOCAL
CHILD CARE IT WILL SUPPORT
CHILD DEVELOPMENT. PARENTS
ABILITY TO WORK TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ECONOMY. AND GENDER
EQUITY BECAUSE MOTHERS WITH
DEPENDABLE CHILDCARE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO WORK AND CAN ADVANCE
PROFESSIONALLY AND FINANCIALLY.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER KAY HAND SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS
WILL DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ROLE TELL A VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS DOCTOR QUIRK I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT. YES MY SON
MARRIED A WONDERFUL WOMAN THIS
SATURDAY. AND THEY HAVE A COAT
OF ARMS. MY SON IS A T. REX OF
MY DAUGHTER IN LAW IS A LEOPARD
THEY HAVE MUSIC SURFING IN
COMMON THEY ALSO HAVE ON THE
SHIELD. SHE'S INVOLVED IN THE
MEDICAL INDUSTRY SHE DOES.
WATER SKIING THEY BOTH DO SIR
FOURTEEN AND HE'S INVOLVED IN
ENERGY SO WONDERFUL WEDDING
FANTASTIC AND A NEW FAMILY
SHE'LL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR QUIRK. THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
AUGUST TWENTIETH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY
FIRST CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY SECOND
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO A
GERMAN TO MEMORY. MEMBERS A
QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE FIND YOUR DESKS.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
RECOGNIZE. A MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR THE VICTIMS OF OUR NATION'S
RECENT MASS SHOOTINGS INCLUDING
THE TRAGEDIES IN GILROY
CALIFORNIA. EL PASO TEXAS. IN
DAYTON OHIO. MEMBERS PLEASE
RISE FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE
TO HONOR REMEMBER THESE VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES
. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MR ROBERT RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU. HOME TO
THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
HAVE HELPED TO BUILD OUR
AGRICULTURAL REGION INTO AN
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE. THE CITY
OF YOUR IS LOCATED IN THE HEART
OF THE THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. IS THE CITY. MADE
FAMOUS BECAUSE IT IS THE GARLIC
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. AND HOME
TO THE ANNUAL THE GILROY THE
GARLIC FESTIVAL. BUT THIS YEAR
THIS A FAMILY FRIENDLY EVENT
WAS MARKED. BY A TRAGIC EVENT.
IT BECAME THE MOST RECENT CITY
THE MOST RECENT THE COMMUNITY
EVENT WHICH EXPERIENCE AN
UNCONSCIONABLE ACT OF GUN
VIOLENCE AND BLOODSHED. IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS TRAGEDY. I
STOOD WITH I STOOD AND ANGRY
Và FAMILIES. WITH FRIENDS AND
THOUSANDS OF YOUR RESIDENCE. WE
HONORED THOSE THAT WERE INJURED
IN THIS TRAGEDY. AND REMEMBER
THE THREE VICTIMS THAT WERE
KILLED. STEPHEN ROMERO AGE SIX.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE KID. HE
CERTAINLY WASN'T KNOWN FOR
BEING SHY AS HE WOULD TALK TO
ANYONE IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD. HE
JUST GRADUATED FROM
KINDERGARTEN. AND PEOPLE WHO
KNEW HIM DESCRIBE HIS KIND
HAPPY AND PLAYFUL. HE WAS WEEKS
AWAY FROM STARTING THE FIRST
GRADE. AND HE WAS SO EXCITED
ABOUT HIS FUTURE. TREVOR HERBY
AGE TWENTY FIVE HE WAS A
BIOLOGY MAJOR WHO GRADUATED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FROM
COLLEGE. THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE SCHOOL TREVOR ATTENDED IN
IN NEW YORK. HE DESCRIBED HIM
AS A TALENTED ATHLETE IN
OUTGOING STUDENT. THE TYPE OF
STUDENT WHO WOULD WHO WHO COULD
BRING JOY AND LASTING COMFORT
TO ANYONE HE MET. KAYLA SALAZAR
AGE THIRTEEN. SHE LOVE MARIO
BROTHERS AND POKEMON. AND HAD A
PET SHE WHILE I NAME LUCKY. SHE
WANTED TO BE AN ANIMATION
ARTIST WE SHE GREW UP. SHE
CARED VERY DEEPLY ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE AND ALWAYS ALWAYS WENT
OUT OF HER WAY TO BRIGHTEN UP
EVERY WEDNESDAY. HER FATHER HE
DESCRIBED HER AS A NEW JOB
AUTUMN. THE FIRE. SO TODAY I
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
JOSE IN SCOTT'S VALLEY AS WE
ADJOURN IN THEIR MEMORY. IN THE
MEMORY OF STEVEN TREVOR AND
KAYLA. WE HONOR OUR COMMUNITY
OUR REGION. OUR BRAVE FIRST
RESPONDERS NOT CREDIBLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY LIVES WILL
NEVER BE THE SAME AFTER THIS
INCIDENT. THAT WE MUST DO ALL
THAT WE CAN OUR CITIES OR
COUNTIES AND CERTAINLY OUR
STATE. TO SUPPORT THOSE THAT
WERE AFFECTED BY THIS TRAGEDY.
FROM A LOCAL RESIDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND IN THE FACE OF THIS
SENSELESS BLOODSHED AND
VIOLENCE. OUR COMMUNITY HAS
JOINED TOGETHER. SHOWN
COMPASSION TOWARDS ONE ANOTHER
AND A WILLINGNESS. A
WILLINGNESS TO FIGHT FOR WHAT
IS RIGHT. IN CARING FOR THE
SPIRIT OF STEVEN TREVOR YOU
KAYLA AND THEY MEAN IT THE MANY
OTHER INNOCENT LIVES WHO HAVE
TRAGICALLY GONE BEFORE THEM. WE
MUST MAKE SURE THAT WE COMMIT
OURSELVES TO LIEU JOB. TO FIGHT
FIGHT FOR A MORE JUST AND SAFE
WORLD FOR OUR CHILDREN AND ALL
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISS
RIVAS MISTER KALRA YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS TO GERMANY
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE. FROM GILROY I
KNOW HOW HARD THIS IS BEEN FOR
EVERYONE I KNOW. THAT OUR DEAR
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE IS. DONE
EVERYTHING HE HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO DO TO KEEP THE COMMUNITY
TOGETHER AND POSITIVE SPIRITS
AND. WHENEVER THERE'S A LIGHT
THAT'S LOST. IN IN SUN SO
SENSELESS GUN VIOLENCE IT'S A
TRAGEDY BUT WHEN IT'S CHILDREN
APPEALS EXCEPT A PUNCH TO THE
GUT EVEN WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW
THE CHILDREN LET ALONE THOSE
WHO ARE THEIR LOVED ONES WHO
WILL NEVER EVER BE ABLE TO
HAVE. THE SAME COULD THAT THEIR
LIFE RESTORED AGAIN. THE GORE
GARLIC FESTIVAL IS A REGIONAL
DRAW. AND MANY OF THOSE THAT
ATTEND ARE FROM SAN JOSE.
INCLUDING MANY PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW THAT WERE THERE. THAT OF
TOLD ME ABOUT THE HORROR OF
BEING THERE AND- BARELY BE ABLE
TO ESCAPE WITH THEIR LIVES. IT
IS WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I
RISE. WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GILROY TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
THE TWO CHILDREN THAT LOST
THEIR LIVES KAYLA CELLS ARE AND
STEVEN ROMERO. UP. AS I
MENTIONED BOTH FROM SAN JOSE IN
LOSS OF LIVES OF THE GARLIC
FESTIVAL BORN AUGUST FOURTH IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE. KILLER
SALAZAR WAS LOVED
UNCONDITIONALLY BY HER FATHER
ONE SALAS OUR MOTHER THE RIGHT
NOW. COMMENTED PIMENTEL DAY
SALAZAR AND HER WHOLE FAMILY.
SHE HAD MANY TALENTS AND
PASSIONS. SHE HAD A LOVE FOR
ART WHO WAS KNOWN FOR HER
CREATIVITY AND UNENDING DESIRE
TO CARE FOR ANIMALS. SHE WAS
ALWAYS CARING FOR DOGS LUCKY
AND CINNAMON HER GUINEA PIG
ALBERT RABBIT MISS JACKSON OR
CAT ROSY. SHE WAS FULL OF LIFE
WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR A
COURAGEOUS MISS AND DESIRE TO
DO WELL IN SCHOOL. HER GREATEST
HOPES PURSUE A CAREER IN
ANIMATION DESIGNING AND
CREATING CHARACTERS AND STORIES.
KAYLA CELLS ARE WOULD HAVE
CELEBRATED HER FOURTEENTH
BIRTHDAY THE WEEK AFTER THE
SHOOTING AT THE COMMUNITY CAME
TOGETHER TO GIVE HER A BIRTHDAY
PARTY. AND ABSENCE. SHE WAS
LAID TO REST ON AUGUST SIXTH.
STEPHEN ROMERO HAD BARELY
CELEBRATED SIX BIRTHDAY A MONTH
BEFORE HE LOST HIS LIFE ON THAT
TRAGIC DAY. HE WAS ATTENDING
THE POSSIBLE WITH HIS MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER BOTH OF WHOM
WERE SHOT. STEPHEN WAS KNOWN BY
HIS FAMILY FOR HIS HIGH ENERGY
LAUGHTER AND KINDNESS. HE LOVED
MUSIC COMIC BOOKS AND BATMAN.
WHEN IT CAME TO MUSIC HE WAS A
FAN OF ROMANTIC BALLADS SUCH AS
THOSE BY THE BAND. BY THE
ARTIST THE WEEKEND. ANOTHER
MEMORABLE TRAIT WAS HIS ABILITY
TO ALWAYS DRESS SHIRT. EVER THE
GENTLEMAN STEPHEN WOULD ALWAYS
VERY NICELY PRESSURES AND NEVER
FEEL TO GO THE EXTRA STEP OF
ADDING COLOGNE TO COMPLETE HIS
REPERTOIRE. EVEN AS A SIX YEAR
OLD. STEPHEN WAS LAID TO REST
ON AUGUST TWELFTH. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING IN
MEMORY OF KILLER SALAZAR AND
STEVEN ROMERO. AVIS KALRA.
MISTER STONE YOU'RE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS THE GERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I JOIN
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM HOLLISTER
IN SAN JOSE ASKING TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY. OF THREE WHO DIED
WITH YET ANOTHER SENSELESS
TRAGEDY IN TRAGEDY COMING FROM
FAILED FEDERAL FIREARMS
POLICIES. AND UNDERSCORING OUR
NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO MORE.
TREVOR HERBY CAME TO SANTA CRUZ
THOUGH HE'S JUST TWENTY FIVE TO
JOIN HIS GIRLFRIEND AND WAS
WORKING AS A NURSE IN A MEDICAL
FACILITY IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
IN FACT THEY WERE GOING
PLANNING TO MOVE BACK TO NEW
YORK SO HE CAN BECOME A
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANT. THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO HAD DEDICATED HIS
LIFE. TO HELPING OTHER PEOPLE
AND HE WAS SENSELESSLY KILLED
IN THIS TRAGEDY HIS GRANDMOTHER
WHO HAD JUST BURIED HER HUSBAND
IN THE FACT TREVOR WAS
RECENTLY. TAKEN BACK. TO NEW
YORK TO BE BURIED ALONGSIDE OF
HIS GRANDFATHER'S OF THIS
FAMILIES SUFFERING ADDITIONAL
TRAGEDIES. BUT IT'S GRANDMOTHER
DID SAY THE TREVOR WAS THE KID
SHE NEVER HAD TO DISCIPLINE.
AND FOR A GRANDMOTHER TO SAY
THAT OF A GRAND CHILDHOOD
ESPECIALLY. THE GRAND SON THAT
IS WE ALL KNOW A REMARKABLE
THING WHEN GRANDMOTHERS DON'T
HAVE TO DISCIPLINE GRANDSON.
THIS WAS A YOUNG MAN FULL OF
LIFE AND ENERGY AND A SMILE. IT
THAT WAS INFECTIOUS. AND
TOUCHED EVERYONE HE HAD MET.
MEMBERS I HOPE WE DON'T HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO STAND FOR THESE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN BUT ON THIS
ONE I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR US TO
SPEAK OUT. AN. ASSET WE
ADJOURNED AND THE MEMORY OF
THESE VICTIMS OF THIS SENSELESS
TRAGEDY. THANK YOU MISTER STONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MEMBERS IT IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TODAY'S
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
CAUCUS TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF ROLE AND MARIA
FLORES. WHO. WITH TWENTY OTHERS
WERE UNJUSTLY KILLED ON AUGUST
THE THIRD IN EL THE EL PASO
SHOOTING THE LARGEST DOMESTIC
TERRORISM ATTACK TARGETING
LATINOS IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
IN SIXTY IN THE SIXTY YEARS
THEY WERE MARRIED ROLE IN MY
IDEA REPRESENTED THAT PAID ME
OF THE AMERICAN DREAM. WHILE
THEY MET IN MEXICO CITY OF SEAT
THE MEXICAN CITY OF CIUDAD
JUAREZ THEY CHOSE TO CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR LIVES. AS
YOUNG ADULTS THEY RAISE THEIR
FAMILY AROUND THE HILLS OF THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THEY RAISE THREE
CHILDREN ELEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
AND TEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
AND WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE MORE
ON THE WAY. ROLL WORKED AS A
PAINTER FOR MOST OF HIS LIFE
AND WAS KNOWN AS HAVING A
STRONG WORK ETHIC IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY. MEDI
I'D KNOWN AS GRAHAM OF FLORIDA
AS LOVE TO COOK INTO EXACTLY
WHAT EVERYONE IN HER FAMILY
LOVE TO EAT VISITING FAMILY
MEMBERS WOULD ALWAYS FIND THEIR
FAVORITE DISHES WAITING FOR
THEM. HAVEN'T RETIRED IN EL
PASO. THE FLORES FAMILY. BECAME
SPLIT BETWEEN THE TEXAS AND
CALIFORNIA STATES. WILL WAS
SCHEDULED TO HAVE OPEN HEART
SURGERY ON AUGUST THE FIFTH IN
ORDER TO BE WITH HIM MEMBERS OF
FAMILY CONVERGED ON EL PASO. ON
THE DAY OF THE SHOOTING BATTLE
IN MY AREA WERE BUYING AIR BEDS
FOR VISITING RELATIVES. THEY
WERE DESCRIBED BY FAMILY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS
INSEPARABLE AND THE ONLY
COMFORT THAT THEIR RELATIVES
TAKEN THEIR DEATH. IS THAT EVEN
AT THE END ROLL AND MARIA WERE
NOT SEPARATED. HOWEVER DEMAND
FUELED BY HATE AND RACISM
REFERRAL MONEY AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILY FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS THE SHOOTING IN EL PASO
WAS NOT A RANDOM ACT IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY TARGETED. IT WAS
METICULOUSLY PREMEDITATED
FUELED AND ENABLED BY PUBLIC
RHETORIC THE TARGETS A BILL
FIVE IMMIGRANTS LATINOS IN IN
PARTICULAR MEXICAN MEXICAN
AMERICANS. WITH THE HIGHEST
LEADER IN OUR COUNTRY
CONTINUOUSLY TARGETING LATINOS.
CALLING US CRIMINALS RAPIST ON
AMERICAN AND EVEN ANIMALS. THE
SHOOTER WAS SO INFLUENCED BY
THE RHETORIC OF WHAT HE CALLED
A SO CALLED INVASION OF THE
BORDER. THAT HE ADMITTED TO
DRIVING TEN HOURS TO ALL PASSED
SO JUST TO TARGET MEXICANS.
THIS INCIDENT IS THE LATEST IN
A LONG HISTORY OF HATE CRIMES
AND VIOLENCE AGAINST LET PENAL.
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN THIS COUNTRY. IN THIS LIGHT.
I ASK A UNIFIED BODY TO
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO COMBAT
ALL FORMS OF BIGOTRY AND HATE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. HATE CRIMES
AND VIOLENCE LIKE THE TYPE WE
SAW IN EL PASO CANNOT CONTINUE
BEING THE NORM. WE MUST REJECT
THIS RHETORIC THAT CAUSES IT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THIS KIND OF HATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU JOIN A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF ROLE
IN MEDI OF FLORES. AND THE
OTHER TWENTY VICTIMS OF THE EL
PASO MASSACRE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO RETURN IN THE MEMORY OF CAL
FIRE FIRE FIGHTER JAROSLAW GORE
**** CUT BECAUSE OF ESCONDIDO.
YAROSLAV WAS BORN ON DECEMBER
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN NINETY TO
NADIA AND IGOR CUT COSTS IN
KHARKOV UKRAINE BEFORE
EMIGRATING TO AMERICA IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. HIS FAMILY
FIRST SETTLED IN TENNESSEE
BEFORE MOVING TO THE SAN DIEGO
AREA IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
YAROSLAV ATTENDED SCRIPTS RANCH
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE
PARTICIPATED IN SEVERAL SPORTS
INCLUDING FOOTBALL TRACK
WRESTLING EVEN WINNING THE SAN
DIEGO CITY CHAMPIONSHIP IN
WRESTLING. AFTER GRADUATION HE
WENT ON TO EARN A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN FINANCE FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY. HIS
DESIRE TO SERVE OTHERS LED HIM
TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
FIREFIGHTING. HE TOOK CLASSES
AT MIRAMAR COLLEGE AND SERVES
AS A SAN DIEGO COUNTY RESERVE
FIREFIGHTER ASSIGNED TO FIRE
STATION NUMBER SEVENTY NINE ON
PALOMAR MOUNTAIN. JAROSLAW WAS
HIRED BY CAL FIRE IN AUGUST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WAS
ASSIGNED TO FIRE STATION NUMBER
SIXTEEN AND TO LOSE WHERE HE
CONTINUED TO DEMONSTRATE THE
VALUES OF PROFESSIONALISM
INTEGRITY TRUST AND COMMITMENT.
FIGHTER FIREFIGHTER JAROSLAW
KAKO PASSED AWAY TRAGICALLY ON
JULY TWENTY NINTH HE WAS ONLY
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OLD AFTER
EXPERIENCING A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY WHILE ON A TRAINING
HIKE TO PREPARE FOR THE
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS GIRLFRIEND
ASHLEY HIS PARENTS IGOR AND
NADIA HIS BROTHER SAM AND HIS
FAMILY OF COLLEAGUES FROM THE
FIRE SERVICE HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO SERVING OTHERS. AND HIS
DEDICATION TO PROTECTING HIS
COMMUNITY ALONG WITH OUR
SACRAMENTO CITY FIREFIGHTERS
WHO ARE HERE WITH US TODAY
ALONG WITH CAL FIRE AND OUR
SEVENTY FIFTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON. MR
MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO GERMAN THE
MEMORY OF ANDRE MARIE'S VûI
JUNIOR. A LOVING FAMILY MAN AND
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICER. THOUGH ANDRE SERVICE
WITH THE CHP WAS CUT TRAGICALLY
SHORT HE HAD GAINED THE RESPECT
OF HIS PEERS AND THE COMMUNITY
HE SERVED. ANDRE WAS BORN AT
MARCH AIR FORCE BASE IN
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND
GRADUATED FROM VALLEY VIEW HIGH
SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. WHERE HE WAS A MEMBER OF
THE MARCHING BAND. FOLLOWING
HIGH SCHOOL AT THE AGE OF
NINETEEN HE APPLIED TO THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. IT
WAS ASKED TO RE APPLY WHEN HE
WAS TWENTY ONE. AFTER A YEAR
AND A HALF. ANDRE AND HIS
FATHER STARTED THEIR OWN
COMPANY HE WOULD GO ON TO WORK
WITH HIS FATHER FOR MORE THAN
TEN YEARS BEFORE APPROACHING
HIS MOTHER. DO YOU THINK IT'S
CRAZY THAT I APPLY FOR THE C.
H. P. AGAIN. HIS MOTHER REPLIED
ABSOLUTELY NOT. NEVER STOP
PURSUING YOUR DREAMS. HE RE
APPLIED AND WAS ACCEPTED AND
BECAME PART OF CTC THREE
SIXTEEN HE GRADUATED FROM THE
C. H. P. ACADEMY ON MARCH THIRD
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHERE HE
WAS ASSIGNED TO THE RIVERSIDE
AREA. HE EARNED THE STATUS OF
CHP MOTOR OFFICER WITHIN HIS
FIRST YEAR. IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN HUNDRED MET THE LOVE
IT WAS LIFE SERRA. THEY ENJOYED
THEIR TIME TRAVELLING RIDING
DIRT BIKES JET SKIS AND GOING
ON ROAD TRIPS. ANDRE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SARAH. IS
LOVING EXTENDED FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND AS C. H. P. FAMILY
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF ANDRE MARIE'S MORNING
JUNIOR. THANK YOU MISTER ARENA
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TO
REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
DURING THE MEMORY. OF MY FRIEND
MARK SORT OF AN- AFTER
GRADUATING WITH BOTH BACHELOR'S
AND MASTER'S DEGREES FROM USC
IN CINEMA. MARK WORKED IN THE
MOTION PICTURE AND TELEVISION
INDUSTRY IS A WRITER PRODUCTION
EXECUTIVE AND ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR HE
TRADED THAT SUCCESSFUL CAREER
TO BECOME A FULL TIME
ENVIRONMENTALIST. MARK WAS THE
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE
PERCENT AT THE GLENDALE PERCENT
OF VOLUNTEERS ORGANIZED IN
CONSERVING THE ENVIRONMENT OR
VOICE I GREW THE ORGANIZATION
FROM A HANDFUL OF INDIVIDUALS
TO A POWER HOUSE OVER NEARLY
FOUR THOUSAND DONOR SUPPORTERS
AND VOLUNTEERS. WITH MARX HELP.
THESE ACTIVISTS HELP TO
PRESERVE OF. VERY LARGE HILL
CITING GLENDALE FROM OUT OF
SCALE INAPPROPRIATE DEVELOPMENT.
FOR DECADES HAS ADVOCACY
FOCUSED ON THE PROTECTION AND
PRESERVATION OF OPEN SPACE HE
SERVED ON THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY AND ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
BOLSA CHICA LAND TRUST. NO ONE
TO PUT HIS FEET UP IN
RETIREMENT HE WORKED FOR YEARS
FOR THE CITY OF GLENDALE AND
SECURED OVER SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF FUNDING
THROUGH FIFTEEN GRANTS TO
SUPPORT LOCAL PARKS AND
COMMUNITY CENTERS. AND I CAN
TELL YOU AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
BROUGHT HER DAUGHTER MANY TIMES
TO DIFFERENT EVENTS IN THE
PARKS AND GONE MYSELF. IT WAS
HARD TO GO TO AN EVENT IN
GLENDALE FEATURING ONE OF OUR
PARKS AND NOT HAVE MARK
STURDIVANT THEIR VOLUNTEERING
IN HIS OFF HOURS TO HELP OUT.
FOR THE PAST TWELVE YEARS MARK
WORKED TIRELESSLY IN THE FIGHT
TO SAVE THE PRODUJO IS GOLF
COURSE AND A HUNGER IN THE TO
HUNGER NEIGHBORHOOD OF LOS
ANGELES. THE COURSE IS THE SITE
OF A OF THE FORMER LA TUNA
CANYON DETENTION CENTER WHICH
HOUSE MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
JAPANESE ITALIANS GERMANS
IMPROVE THE INS OF JAPANESE
DESCENT. AFTER THE ONSLAUGHT OF
WORLD WAR TWO. FROM THE MAPLE
PARKING COMMUNITY CENTER TO
DICK MEIJIN PARK IN THE
GLENDALE NARROWS RIVER WALK.
MARK TRANSFORMED OUR REGION AND
ENSURED THAT GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO AN
INCREDIBLE ARRAY OF OUTDOOR
ACTIVITIES. AND MARK WAS
SOMEONE. THAT IF YOU MET HIM
YOU WOULDN'T REALIZE THAT HE
HAD HAD HIS HAND IN SO MANY OF
THESE IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES IN
THE CITY. HE WAS VERY QUIET
VERY SOFT SPOKEN HE NEVER
CALLED ATTENTION TO HIMSELF HE
NEVER STOOD UP IN THE PUBLIC
AND REALLY SAID I AM THE PERSON
BEHIND ANY OF THIS. HE WAS JUST
ALWAYS KIND OF THERE BUT HE
SPENT ALL OF HIS TIME. WORKING
ON HIS PASSION OF PRESERVATION
AND CONSERVATION AND HIS IF
YOU. REALLY PAID ATTENTION YOU
WOULD SEE MARK'S HAND IN ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS.
AS A VOLUNTEER AND AS AN
REALLY SOMETHING TO BEHOLD HE
WAS VERY QUIET AND SOFT SPOKEN.
BUT HIS VOICE CARRIED A LOT OF
WEIGHT AND A LOT OF POWER. THE
COMMUNITY HAS LOST AN AMAZING
ADVOCATE AN OUTSTANDING MAN.
OUR DEEPESTCONDOLENCES CAN
DON'T ONCE IS GO OUT TO HIS
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART AND WIFE
OF NEARLY FORTY NINE YEARS.
GENET HIS DAUGHTERS BETHANY IN
KIMBERLY HIS SON IN LAW ROGER
AND GRANT SUCH ABOUT SEBASTIAN
AS WELL AS HIS SISTER. JILL
MARK WILL BE MISSED NOT JUST BY
ME AND THE COMMUNITY IN
GLENDALE BUT ALSO BY THE
MOUNTAINS AND THE RIVERS. THE
HAWKS THE MOUNTAIN LIONS THAT
HE WORKS SO HARD TO PROTECT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MS FREEMAN A MISTER IS
THERE IN YOUR ALSO RECOGNIZE
SOME THIS IS GERMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I. WANTED TO
ALSO RISE IN RECOGNIZING MARK
STIRRED OF AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GLENDALE SPOKE VERY
ELOQUENTLY MARK WAS A DEAR
FRIEND I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET TO KNOW HIM WHEN. THE
GLENDALE COMMUNITY THE LOOK AT
A GREATER EL GLENDALE COMMUNITY
ACTIVATED AND BEGAN THEIR WORK
IN PURCHASING THE STATE AT THE
STATE AT THE TIME MADE A MAJOR
INVESTMENT IN PURCHASING
PORTIONS OF OAKMONT FIVE
PROPERTY AND THAT'S WHEN I
STARTED TO GET TO KNOW MARK AND
WORK WITH HIM AND AS AMAZED AS
I WAS WITH HIS WORK ON FRAZIER
FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS AS- MY
COLLEAGUE. PREVIOUSLY ALLUDED.
THE HUMILITY AND THE HUMOR THAT
HE BROUGHT TO ANY ROOM OR ANY
WORKING GROUP WAS AMAZING. AND
AS YOU KNOW. OF GIVEN HIS
BACKGROUND IN PRODUCTION YOU
COULD ALSO SEE. HOW FOCUSED HE
WAS IN MAKING SURE WITH A VERY
SOFT VOICE PUSHING PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS FORWARD WITH A VERY
KIND AND GENTLE SMILE. THAT WAS
EXTREMELY DISARMING SO MY LOVE
TO CHEN THAT KIMBERLY AND
BETHANY AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING AN ADJOINING HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANY
MEMORY. I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AT AS I RISE TO
A DURING THE MEMORY OF MY UNCLE
WHO WAS A VETERAN OF NOT ONE
BUT TWO WARS IT IS THAT BY
THINK IT BEARS NOTING THAT WE
ARE DOING MULTIPLE ADJOURNMENT
MEMORIES FOR PEOPLE DIED OF GUN
VIOLENCE. IN OUR COUNTRY AS I
BEGIN TO DO AN A GERMAN MEMORY
OF MY UNCLE WHO DIED AT EIGHTY
NINE. AFTER FIGHTING WARS
OVERSEAS. A GUNNERY SERGEANT
ANDREW MAX EGGMAN UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS RETIRED WAS BORN
JUNE SIXTH NINETEEN THIRTY IN
GRIDLEY CALIFORNIA AND PASSED
AWAY AUGUST THIRD. AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY NINE AT HIS HOME
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY. HE
SERVED TWENTY NINE YEARS IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS AND
RETIRES A GUNNERY SERGEANT. HE
WAS IN THE KOREAN WAR THE
CHOSEN RESERVOIR KNOWN AS ONE
OF THE CHOSEN FEW. AND THEN HE
RETURNED TO COMBAT DURING
VIETNAM HE EARNED A PURPLE
HEART. PRESIDENTIAL UNIT
CITATIONS GOOD CONDUCT METALS
AND THE NATIONAL DEFENSE MEDAL.
AFTER YEARS RETIREMENT FROM THE
UNITED STATES MARINES HE WAS I
WENT TO THE FAMILY BUSINESS TO
BE KEEPING. AN EYE OUT WAS A AT
ONE TIME THE PRISON THE
CALIFORNIA BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION. IT WORKED WELL
INTO HIS EIGHTIES WHERE HE
BEEKEEPER AND TAKEN HONEY UP.
EVERY WEEK TO A SAN FRANCISCO
FARMERS MARKET TWICE A WEEK
WHERE HE WOULD SELL. HE WAS
MARRIED TO MY AUNT. AND HAD
THREE CHILDREN. JAMIE ANDREW
AND MICHAEL WITH A STEPDAUGHTER
FROM HIS WIFE'S FIRST MARRIAGE
OR IN. HE REMARRIED TWENTY NINE
YEARS AGO. LIFE MY AT CHAIN WHO
COULD LAST WELL INTO HER
NINETIES. SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF MY
UNCLE MAX EGGMAN. THE HE IS WAS
THAT SIXTH OF SIX OF MY
GRANDPARENTS CHILDREN THERE IS
ONE LAST. EGGMAN STANDING. AND
I WISH YOU UNCLE MAC NUMBER.
THANK YOU DOCTOR A MAN. MS
RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF US TO SEND I LEFT A
AYE YEAH Là ALSO CENTERS LIFE
WAS TRAGICALLY CUT SHORT WHEN A
GUNMAN THAT HAD ALREADY KILLED
OTHERS IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY OPENED FIRE AND KILLED
HER WHILE SHE WAS AT WORK AT A
GAS STATION IN NORTH HOLLYWOOD.
ASSISTANT I WAS BORN IN HOLLY
SCHOOL MAY HE GOAL AND BECAME A
PROUD CALIFORNIA GIRL AT THE
AGE OF TEN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE WHEN HER MATT FAMILY MOVED
TO THE UNITED STATES SHE WAS A
RESIDENT OF NORTH HOLLYWOOD
WHERE SHE WORKED AS A CLERK FOR
A LOCAL GAS STATION. SHE WILL
BE REMEMBERED FOR HER DIMPLES
SMILE HER SENSE OF HUMOR AND
BEAUTIFUL PERSONALITY SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER FOUR CHILDREN
THREE DAUGHTERS AND ONE SON
JOIN THE MARINES NEXT YEAR THE
NORTH HOLLYWOOD COMMUNITY. AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY NINE
WILL MISS ALSO SEND NOT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY TODAY
THANK. THANK YOU MS RIVAS MISS
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANY MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF BARBARA TAURUS A
DEDICATED PARTY AND LABOR
ACTIVISTS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
WARRIOR WHO UNEXPECTEDLY PASSED
AWAY JULY THIRTEENTH OVER
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS SHE WAS
ONLY THIRTY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
BARBARA WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
EAST LA AND GRADUATED FROM
GARFIELD HIGH SCHOOL SHE WAS A
PROUD BULLDOG SHE LOVED HER
COMMUNITY. AT FOURTEEN BARBARA
BECAME A STUDENT WORKER. WHICH
LED TO HER CAREER AT THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DURING HER NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SAID ELIE UST SHE SPENT
TWENTY OF THOSE YEARS ASSISTING
THE NEEDIEST OF STUDENTS A
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARA
PROFESSIONAL. BARBARA BELIEVE
THAT ALL CHILDREN SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO A QUALITY EDUCATION.
AND NO MATTER THEIR INCOME OR
LANGUAGE SKILLS THEY SHOULD BE
PROVIDED WITH THE RESPECT AND
DIGNITY THAT WE ALL DESERVE. TO
PROPERLY SERVE THE STUDENTS
HAVE A U. S. T. BARBARA KNEW
THAT HER COWORKERS SHOULD HAVE
ALL THE TOOLS TRAINING AND
RESPECT THAT THEIR PROFESSION
DEMANDED. THAT IS WHEN SHE
STARTED HER CAREER SO LABOR
ADVOCATE. BARBARA WAS THE FIRST
AND YOUNGEST PERSON TO SERVICE
THE PRESIDENT OF SEIU LOCAL
NINETY NINE SHE REPRESENTED
OVER FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
EDUCATION WORKERS AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS EARLY
EDUCATION CENTERS HOMES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MANY
MEMBERS IN THIS HOUSE AND IN
THE SENATE HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
BARBARA'S ACTIVISM. AND
COUNTLESS HOURS THAT SHE
VOLUNTEERED ON CAMPAIGNS IF YOU
KNEW BARBARA YOU KNEW THAT YOU
WANTED HER ON YOUR SIDE. I
WASN'T AS LUCKY SHE ACTUALLY
RAN AGAINST ME FOR THIS
ASSEMBLY SEAT. AND BY DOING SO
SHE MADE ME A BETTER CANDIDATE
AND ULTIMATELY A BETTER LEADER.
SINCE HER UNTIMELY PASSING I
HAVE OFTEN THOUGHT ABOUT A
CONVERSATION WE HAD WHILE
HAVING COFFEE ANY SELLING. YOU
CAN'T FORGET ABOUT US WENDY SHE
TOLD ME YOU CAN'T FORGET ABOUT
THE KIDS. AND I PROMISED HER
THAT I WOULDN'T. LOCALLY SHE
SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF THE
FIFTY FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
DELEGATION FOR THE LA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. AND AS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SHE PLAYED A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN INCREASING THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT HISTORIC PHOTO OVER
GOVERNOR BROWN. YOU WILL SEE
BARBARA RIGHT NEXT TO HIM.
BARBARA WAS A FRIEND OF THE
WORKER. AND A CHAMPION OF
UNDERDOGS SHE WAS HOPEFUL AND
EXCITED FOR WHAT THE FUTURE
WOULD BRING. HER PASSING SENT
SHOCKWAVES THROUGH LOS ANGELES
POLITICAL CIRCLES AND WE OWE IT
TO HER AND HER LOVE OF THIS
STATE. TO PASS MEANINGFUL
POLICY THAT INSURERS EVERY
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. BARBARA
SURVIVED BY HER SIBLINGS
CATHERINE FRANCE'S ROLE JULIAN
JUNIOR SHE LEAVES BEHIND HER
PRECIOUS NIECES BREANNA TRIANA.
RAVEN WHOM SHE LOVED AND
SUPPORTED. HER ABSENCE IS FELT
DEEPLY IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE AND THROUGHOUT OUR
GREAT STATE. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS KOREA MISTER SANTIAGO
YOU'RE ALSO RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THEY AYE
RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART ALSO TO
TALK ABOUT OUR FRIEND BARBARA.
AND MOST OF US WHO KNEW ARBOR
CANTIK BARBARA CAN HELP BUT THE
SMILE THEY REMEMBER HER FIST IN
THE AIR. BULL HORN IN HAND
SCREAMING AND YELLING AT YOU
TELLING YOU TO MOVE QUICKER DO
WE NEED TO PROTEST AND I KNOW
SEE THE SMILES AROUND BECAUSE
THAT'S- THAT'S THE KIND OF
PERSON SHE WAS. AND I THINK
IT'S TRUE BECAUSE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THAT WELL
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL MOST OF US IN LA COUNTY
REMEMBER THAT THE FIGHT FOR
FIFTEEN REALLY. WAS ALMOST LIKE
A SYMBOL OF BARBARA'S LIFE.
WHETHER YOU WERE SERVING TO
KEEP IT COLLEGE BOARD AND I DID
AT THE TIME. WHEN SHE BEGAN
THAT OR L. A. U. S. T. OR THE
COUNTY. IS ALWAYS BARBARA BORN.
IN A VERY VIVIDLY REMEMBER MY
FIRST YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE.
WHEN I WAS HAPPENING. AND
TAKING MY KID IN A STROLLER.
AND SHE WAS NOT FORGETTING. HE
STILL PUT OUR ARM IN THE AIR.
IS THERE IF THIS PORTABLE HORN
IN MY HEAD SAID MOVE FASTER
MOVE FAST YOU THINK WE GOT TIME
FOR THIS PEOPLE NEED FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR KEEP GOING KEEP
GOING. BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF
PERSON BARBARA WAS. CHOOSE OUR
FRIEND. TO THE DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVIST COMMUNITY LEADER AND
SOMEONE THAT WE ALWAYS KNEW WAS
THERE WHEN YOU NEEDED TO BE
SPECIALLY FOR HER COMMUNITY
AND- THE SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOODS. YEAH WE START
LABOR RALLIES EVERY DEMOCRATIC
ORGANIZATION OR MEETING THAT
HAPPENED SHE WAS THERE. WITHOUT
A DOUBT WHETHER WAS IN HER
DISTRICT ANOTHER DISTRICT. AND
EVEN HERE AT AT IN THE
SACRAMENTO WITH THE LATINO
CAUCUS ONCE HONORED HER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. AND IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART BUT YOU HAD A BIG
SMILE ON MY FACE WHEN I THINK
OF OUR BARBARA LOOKING IT MEANS
AS WELL HECK. I'M JUST TO GO
FROM EAST LA. AND MOST OF US
CAN REMEMBER. THAT BIG SMILE
THAT BIG HUG. HER FIST IN THE
AIR DEMANDING FOURTEEN FOR
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO. SURE
GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO RISE TO
ALSO I'M ONE COME IN MY
COLLEAGUES EVERYTHING THEY SAID
WAS CORRECT EVERYONE WHO KNEW
BARBARA KNEW EXACTLY WHAT THE
INDIVIDUALS FROM LOS ANGELES
HAVE ALREADY ARTICULATED I WAS
JUST LOOKING IS SCROLLING BACK
THE LAST TEXT MESSAGE THAT SHE
AND I SHARE TOGETHER I WON'T
TALK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE AS VERY
PERSONAL BUT SHE ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT THE LITTLE GIRL FROM EAST
LOS ANGELES BUT WAS REALLY AND
THAT'S TO MY MIND. IS ONE
PICTURE. THE PICTURE WITH HER
AND DARREN PARKER. TOGETHER AND
NOW THEY ARE TOGETHER. THERE
WAS GIPSON THIS CARILLO YOUR
AGAIN. AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO HONOR THE MEMORY OF ENRY
LOZANO A LATINO POLITICAL
STRATEGIST AND FRIEND TO MANY
IN LOS ANGELES AND CALIFORNIA.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JULY
FIFTEENTH MISTER LOZANO WAS
BORN AND GREW UP IN HARLINGTON
TEXAS DURING A TIME IN WHICH
THAT THE NOTES WERE FORCED TO
ATTEND SEGREGATED SCHOOLS AT A
TIME IN WHICH THERE WERE SIGNS
THAT READ. NO MEXICANS ALLOWED.
THIS EXPERIENCE SHAPED HIS
PASSION AND DESIRE FOR CHANGE
HE HOPED THAT THE FUTURE OF
LATINOS THE GENERATIONS OF
LATINOS WILL NO LONGER BE
SUBJECTED TO THE POLICIES OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT HE FACED.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL. HE CHOSE TO
SERVE OUR NATION'S MILITARY AN
ENLISTED IN THE MARINES HE
SERVED IN THE KOREAN WAR AND
ROSE TO THE RANK OF CORPORAL HE
LATER JOINED THE AMERICAN GI
FORUM. WHICH HELPS LATINO
VETERANS. AFTER HIS SERVICE HE
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE
HIS EDUCATION. STUDY MACHINERY
AT ALLEY TRADE TECH COLLEGE AND
EAST LA COLLEGE. DURING THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES HE BECAME
INVOLVED IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
FOCUSED ON UP LIFTING HIS
COMMUNITY AND SUPPORTING LATINO
CANDIDATES OR POLITICAL
ASPIRATIONS AND FOUGHT FOR
POLITICAL EQUITY AND
TRANSPARENCY HE BECAME A
COUNSELOR AND CONFIDENT TO MANY
PROMINENT LATINO LEADERS. AND
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
HISTORIC ELECTION OF
CONGRESSMAN EDWARD ROY BALL.
AND WENT ON TO SERVE AS HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF HE WAS A CLOSE
AND PERSONAL FRIEND TO NOW
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YET TO
SET UP. AND PLAYED A KID OR A
CRITIC. WHEN HIS ELECTIONS
TOWARD THE ASSEMBLY AND
CONGRESS AND THE DISTRICT THAT
I NOW HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO
REPRESENT. MR LET'S NOT TO THE
LIVES OF MANY AN IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA IN WAYS THAT HAVE
YET TO BE TOLD. IN TERMS OF HIS
INFLUENCE OVER POLITICS AND
POLICY. WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE HE LOOKED ME STRAIGHT IN
THE EYES. AND TOLD ME THAT THE
STAKES WERE HIGH. AND THAT I
BETTER BE READY. HE DIDN'T MAKE
WORDS A FEW MONTHS AGO HE SAW
ME AT A COMMUNITY EVENT AND
KILEY SAID. I'VE BEEN KEEPING
MY EYE ON YOU AND YOU HAVEN'T
GOTTEN WHERE YOU COME FROM. IF
YOU KNEW MISTER LOZANO YOU
WOULD KNOW THAT THAT WAS
PERHAPS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
COMPLIMENTS. YOU COULD RECEIVE
FROM. WE LOVE THE EAST SIDE HE
LOVED HIS COMMUNITY OF GLASS
CELL PARK HE LOVE LOS ANGELES
HE LOVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND MOST OF ALL HE LOVED THIS
COUNTRY AND BELIEVE IN THE
POLITICAL POWER OF EVERYDAY
PEOPLE MAKING THE IMPOSSIBLE
POSSIBLE. TO MANY MISTER LOZANO
REPRESENTED A TYPE OF POLITICS
BASED ON TRUST RESPECT AND
INTENSE WORK ETHIC. WE OWE A
DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO MISTER
LOZANO IN HIS COMMITMENT TO HIS
FAMILY HIS COMMUNITY OUR STATE
AND OUR NATION. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS EX WIFE ISABEL HIS
SIBLING SAM ROBERT ALICE
GRANDCHILDREN TRICIA ASHLEY
LANE AND HANK AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN TRAVIS SYDNEY
ELIZABETH BECKER JADEN. AND
GABRIEL THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES THE DEATHS
REPORTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SENATE HEARING OF FOR THE
BUSINESS OF READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS. THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SECOND. AT NINE AM IN
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. I
WITH THEM
. I HAVE A CHANGE SB
FOUR OH TO FROM NINE TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE SENATE BILL FOUR OH TWO I
TO KNOW. VOTE CHANGE SB THREE
SIXTEEN GALLAGHER I'D TO NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER SENATE BILL
THREE SIXTEEN I IT'S NOT VOTING.
BUT OUR QUE HAN BO CHANGE SB
FOUR OH TWO FROM I'D TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER QUE HAN SENATE BILL FOUR
OH TWO I TO KNOW
. WE MOAN VOTE
CHANGE SB FOUR OH TWO FROM I TO
NOT VOTING. THE CHANGE AS ONE
MEMBER THE MON SENATE BILL FOUR
OH TWO I TO NOT VOTING. BONTA
VOTE CHANGE AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY I
TO NOT VOTING. SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT CORRECTION SELLABLE
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT